SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GILL. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. YELLOW. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
CIERTO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG WAHAB.
WIENER. WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IF WE CAN KINDLY RETURN
TO OUR DESK. WE ARE GETTING
STARTED. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER BY SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. GUEST AND MEMBERS,
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THEN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. SISTER
SO WE GATHER IN GOD'S PRESENCE.
AND TODAY WE PRAY IN THE WORDS
OF NAT HAHN, WE TURN TOWARD THE
LIGHT OF LOVING KINDNESS TO
DIRECT US. WE BOW DEEPLY TO THE
AWAKENED ONE AND TO OUR
SPIRITUAL ANCESTORS. TODAY WE
BEGIN ANEW TO PURIFY AND FREE
OUR HEARTS WITH IMMEASURABLE
COMPASSION, TO HELP HUMANKIND.
WE RESOLVE TO LIVE BEAUTIFULLY.
MAY OUR HEARTS GARDEN OF
AWAKENING BLOOM WITH HUNDREDS OF
FLOWERS. MAY MOUNTAINS AND
RIVERS BE OUR WITNESS IN THIS
MOMENT. AS WE BOW OUR HEADS AND
REQUEST THE LORD OF COMPASSION
TO EMBRACE US ALL. AMEN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
IS AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS? ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS, WELCOME TO OUR STARS
AND STRIPES. TUESDAY TODAY WE
GOT NO PRIVILEGES UNDER THE
FLOOR. OF THE FLOOR. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
NOW UNDER MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE 29.1, SEE. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES FILE. ITEM 14
AB 518. MEMBERS ANY OTHER
BUSINESS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I AM SEEING NO
MIKES GO UP. SO LET'S GET INTO
THE MEAT OF TODAY. CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH 14 UNDER THE SECOND
READING FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1038 2935 157
158 176 177. SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED READ. WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. MEMBERS, PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. WE HAVE A VERY, VERY LONG
DAY. IT WILL BE EVEN LONGER IF
WE HAVE TO KEEP STOPPING.
STARTING OFF WITH ITEM FIVE,
ITEM 17, SENATOR LAIRD IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATOR LAIRD, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM 17 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CLIFF
RECHTSHAFFEN FOR APPOINTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. PRIOR TO JOINING THE
BOARD, HE SERVED ON THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. HE ALSO PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS SENIOR ADVISOR TO
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN AND AS A
SPECIAL ASSISTANT IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. HE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY 3RD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED, I THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADD MY VOICE BRIEFLY
TO THE DISCUSSION? JUST TO SAY
THAT I'VE WORKED EXTENSIVELY
WITH CLIFF RISTROPH, AND HE'S AN
OUTSTANDING THINKER AND LEADER
ON THE CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION.
AND I URGE SUPPORT OF THIS
NOMINATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SEEING NO OTHER
MIKE. SENATOR LARRY, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR
FROM SAN MATEO COUNTY FOR HIS
COMMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. AYE DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MILO.
OCHOA. BOGH. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO. SEN. LAIRD MOVES A
CAR. MOVING ON TO ITEM 18. SEN.
LAIRD. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT.
FILE ITEM 18 IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF GLORIA ALVARADO FOR
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE SANTA ANA
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD. SHE FIRST JOINED THE
BOARD IN 2021 AND CURRENTLY
SERVES AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY LABOR
FEDERATION. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY 3RD
ON A FIVE. I MEAN, ON AUGUST
SEVENTH ON A50 VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OF ITEM 18? I'M
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY.
DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. TROBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO.
SENATOR LAIRD MOVES THE CALL.
SENATOR LAIRD, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 19. PLEASE PROCEED. Þ THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
A FINAL ITEM 19 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF KIM PATTILLO.
BROWNSON, JAMES MCQUILLAN AND I.
THEY RODRIGUEZ, AS MEMBERS OF
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THESE ARE ALL REAPPOINTMENTS.
MISS PATTILLO BROWNSON IS AN
EDUCATION POLICY CONSULTANT,
FORMERLY VICE PRESIDENT OF FIRST
FIVE LOS ANGELES, SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE 2019. MR. MCQUILLAN
IS A YUROK ENROLLED TRIBAL
CITIZEN FROM DEL NORTE COUNTY,
THE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION FOR
THE YUROK TRIBE, HE SERVED ON
THE BOARD SINCE 2020. MISS
RODRIGUEZ IS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER IN EL CENTRO. SHE HAS
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE 2020.
THEY WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST 14TH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO MIXUP, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
RODA-GIL NO ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO CORTEZ I
DEL DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN NO NILO NO CHOBOQ NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK NO. SENATOR
LAIRD MOVES TO CALL. ALL RIGHT.
NOW MOVING INTO UNFINISHED UNDER.
WE'RE MOVING INTO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. SENATORS. RIGHT NOW ON
THE DESK, WE HAVE 99 BILLS TO
GET THROUGH. I WILL KINDLY
REMIND YOU, IF IT'S A SUPPORT
SUPPORT ASKING, WE CAN KEEP IT
NICE AND SHORT AND SEE IF WE CAN
GET MORE DONE TODAY. SENATOR
JONES, FOR WHAT REASON DO YOU
RISE? NEVER MIND. GREAT THE
FIRST THREE UP ITEMS SO YOU ARE
PREPARED AS FIVE. ITEM 103, 108
AND 109. SENATOR PADILLA, ARE
YOU PREPARED TO KICK US OFF? HE
IS. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ FILE
ITEM 103. ASSEMBLY BILL 2779 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2779 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
IT REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR TO
REPORT ANY NEW USE OF GRID
ENHANCING TECHNOLOGIES,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS GETS, WITH
THEIR RELATED COST AND ENERGY
SAVINGS GETS ENCOMPASS A SUITE
OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN BE
DEPLOYED ON EXISTING
TRANSMISSION LINES TO MAXIMIZE
CURRENT TRANSMISSION CAPACITY IN
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAYS.
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND NO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
MIXUP, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON A BILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN MILO. AYE. TROBOK.
APIDIUM AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. WE STILL HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO BE PUTTING ITEMS ON
CALL. SENATOR PADILLA MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP FOR ITEM 108.
SENATOR DODD ENJOYS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT HE HAS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1768 BY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION ACT RELATING TO
HORSE RACING. SENATOR DODD.
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS AB
1768 SIMPLY UPDATES THE HORSE
RACING LAW BY MAKING TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DODD, I SEE
NO MIX UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. I'LL
GO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY. DODD. AYE DURAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. MILO. AYE.
DROBO. I BELIEVE. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR DODD
MOVES A CALL. SENATOR CIERTO IS
PREPARED FOR A 109. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1892
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORES. AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. SENATOR SERRATO
ENJOYS SUPPORT. SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB 1892
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA. IT EXPANDS THE AUTHORITY
OF JUDGES TO ISSUE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO SEEK
COURT ORDERS AUTHORIZING
WIRETAPPING OR INTERCEPTION OF
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
RELATED RELATED TO FELONY CHILD
RELATED CRIMES. THIS BILL HAS NO
NO VOTES, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ANY AYE VOTE, NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLAN. AYE GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE I.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER EYES. MOORLACH.
RIVAS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR SATO MOVES TO CALL THE
NEXT THREE ON FILE OF ITEM 115,
121 AND 123. SENATOR JONES IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2069 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER. AN ACCOLADE TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. SENATOR
JONES. SUPPORT. SUPPORT I'M NOT
READY FOR THAT ONE. SORRY, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I THOUGHT I WAS
TAKING UP FILE ITEM 25. SORRY.
WE ARE PASSED ON FILE. MOVING ON
TO I HAVE IT. I'M SORRY. WE ARE
BACK ON FILE. FILE ITEM 115.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM PRESENTING FILE
ITEM 115, WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2069 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. THIS BILL RECTIFIES A
DISCREPANCY IN CURRENT LAW
REGARDING THE SALE OF
DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED SOJU. AND
SHOCHU BY ON SALE BEER AND WINE
LICENSED WHOLESALERS CURRENTLY
ON SALE. BEER AND WINE LICENSE
HOLDERS CAN SELL IMPORTED SOJU
AND SHOCHU. HOWEVER, THEY ARE
PROHIBITED FROM SELLING
DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED PRODUCED
SOJU AND SHOCHU, DESPITE MEETING
THE SAME REGULATORY STANDARDS AS
THEIR IMPORTED COUNTERPARTS.
THIS PUTTING CALIFORNIA
PRODUCERS AT A SIGNIFICANT
DISADVANTAGE. MEMBERS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL
2069. THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT.
SUPPORT SPEECH, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM? I'M SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. RAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. OR, DATO. AYE.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. MILO. AYE. JOBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. MOORLACH. RIVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. PADILLA. A AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SEN.
STERN IS PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM
121. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2712 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO LAND USE. SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, THIS IS A RESPONSE TO A
BILL THAT PASSED IN 2022 WHICH
LIMITED OR ELIMINATED MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR CERTAIN
DEVELOPMENTS NEAR MAJOR TRANSIT
STOPS. THIS EASES SOME OF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS TO STILL ALLOW FOR
PARKING, IN CERTAIN AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
BILL, IT EXEMPTS RESIDENTS IN
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS, EXEMPTS RESIDENTS
IN RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE 20 UNITS OR LESS, AND ALSO
HAS SOME DISTRICT IMPLICATIONS.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES,
WHERE RESIDENTS ARE GOING TO BE
ALLOWED AS WELL AS VISITORS OF
CERTAIN DEVELOPMENTS FOR GETTING
PARKING PERMITS AND PREFERENTIAL
PARKING AREAS. THIS WAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, SUPPORT OF
NUMEROUS NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS WE
THINK WILL MAKE HOUSING CRISIS
STILL ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS
WITHOUT RESTRICTING PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO GET PARKING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE. I
AM SEEING NO MIXUP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
I'LL GO. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NØ. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
NO. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO. NO. JOBO NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NO SKINNER.
AYE. SMALL QUAVERS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
NO. WILK NO. RODRIGO. NO JONES.
I DON'T KNOW. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD
GROVE. NO. MCGUIRE WAHAB. AYE
AYES 27. NOES 11. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR DODD, YOU ARE UP
AGAIN. FILE ITEM 123 AB 2047. WE
ARE READY TO GO. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2047
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR DODD. THIS ENJOYS
SUPPORT. SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT 2047 ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MIKE ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG. IT WILL
ESTABLISH A SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE
OF CIVIL RIGHTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
RESPONDING TO AN ASSEMBLY REPORT,
HIGHER EDUCATION REPORT. THEY'LL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES
39. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT THREE ON DECK FIVE. ITEM
137, 141 AND 151. WE'RE
CONTINUING WITH THE SENATE-TV
DODD CHAU. THIS IS HIS THIRD ONE
UP. IN CASE YOU'RE COUNTING FOR
TODAY'S CHAMPION SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 137.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3285 BY
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AN ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL. SENATOR DODD. THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE SUNSET AND THE ABC
ACT BY FIVE YEARS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THERE WE GO.
ANY DISCUSSION? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
FILE ITEM 141. SENATOR CORTESE
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 832 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. SENATORS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 832 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. THIS BILL IS A FOLLOW
UP TO THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S OAN
ASSEMBLY BILL, AB 179 FROM 2017.
THAT BILL WAS APPROVED PASSED
ALL THE SENATE WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW AND THE BILL PREVIOUSLY
URGED THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALS WITH PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ARE
REPRESENTED AMONGST THE VOTING
MEMBERSHIP OF THE CTC. THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS
CERTAINLY HEEDED THAT CALL, BUT
THERE'S NO ASSURANCE THAT IN THE
FUTURE, GOVERNORS WILL DO SO. SO
AB 832 PROVIDES THIS GUARANTEE
BY REQUIRING THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT AT LEAST ONE INDIVIDUAL
WITH PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE IN
EJ AS A VOTING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, SO THAT THIS BILL
REALLY JUST CHANGES THE LANGUAGE
FROM MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO CHAU,
IT'S VITAL THAT THE CTC
CONTINUES TO HAVE PERSPECTIVES
OF THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHEN MAKING
IMPORTANT TRANSPORTATION POLICY
DECISIONS. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
THAT HOPE A REALITY. AND
COLLEAGUES, FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARO DE GILL. NO ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. NO. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NÓ. NHIÀU NO. JOBO. NO.
PODIUM AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NÓ
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO AYES
30. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR ASHBY IS
PREPARED FOR. FIRED ON 151.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1807 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CERVANTES. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR ASHBY. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1807 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. 1807 WILL MAKE
UPDATES TO THE EXISTING
RIVERSIDE COUNTY REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. IT APPLIES STRICTER
PROHIBITIONS ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS OUTSIDE OF PUBLIC
MEETINGS, REQUIRES COMMISSIONERS
TO TRANSLATE MATERIALS ON THE
WEBSITE TO APPLICABLE LANGUAGES
AND BARS COMMISSIONERS FROM
ENDORSING OR MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO RIVERSIDE
CANDIDATES. THESE UPDATES WILL
MAKE THE SUPERVISORS RACES AND
REDISTRICTING PROCESS MORE
TRANSPARENT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I'M SEEING NO
MICS UP, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OAN AYE. GILL. NO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NO. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
CHOBOQ. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL QUAVERS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE AYES 31. AYE. NO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM 152,
155 AND 161. SENATOR BRADFORD IS
PREPARED FOR ITEM 152.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1834 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
1834. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
GARCIA, SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT
THE RELIABILITY PROVISION OF AB
1373, WHICH WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR, CAN BE IMPLEMENTED FAIRLY
WITHOUT INCREASING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS FOR
PUBLIC OWNED UTILITIES. THE BILL
ALSO ENSURES THAT PWS CAN
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE IN THE
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT
PROVISIONS OF AB 1373, USING
FINANCING MECHANISMS THAT BEST
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR NØ MIX UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN AYE. I'LL ROLL TO GO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. AYE.
DODD AYE. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. OR DATO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD AYE.
MCGUIRE. WAYNE. AYE AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR ATKINS HAS FILED ITEM
155. SHE IS READY. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2072
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. SENATOR, THIS ENJOYS
SUPPORT. SUPPORT. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2072 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR WEBBER.
LEGISLATION. CHAPTER IN 2021
ALLOWED ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE TO EMPLOYEES
IN THE LIFE SCIENCES INDUSTRY
THAT HAS WORKED VERY WELL. THE
IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS IN THIS
LEGISLATION HAVE ENSURED THAT
THE PLAN IS SOLVENT, OFFERS
HIGHEST QUALITY CARE AND IS
ACTUALLY ACTUARIALLY SOUND. 2072
REMOVES THE SUNSET ON THE
PROGRAM AND THE AMENDMENTS
ENHANCED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE. WE REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY, AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, ANY ANY
DISCUSSION. ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I SEE NO
OBJECTION. AYES 39. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR DURAZO
HAS FILED ITEM 161. SHE IS READY
TO GO WITH HER RED, WHITE AND
BLUE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2387 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. AN ACT RELATING
TO MOBILE HOME PARKS. SENATOR
JOYCE. THIS ENJOYS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT 20 2387 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE WONDERFUL.
SENATOR, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? DON'T RUIN IT. I SEE
NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO. THE NEXT
THREE ARE FILED. ITEM 162, 168
AND 169. SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 162. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ITEM 162. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2395 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. AN ACT RELATING TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK-SILVA TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2395. AB 2395 WILL PROVIDE
INCREASED FISCAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM TO UTILIZE THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION RESERVE FUND MORE
FLEXIBLY AND MORE EFFECTIVELY,
ALLOWING IT TO BETTER SERVE
STUDENTS AND FULFILL ITS
EDUCATIONAL AND INSTITUTIONAL
MISSION. RECOGNIZING THE STATE'S
CURRENT FISCAL CHALLENGES, THIS
MEASURE DOES NOT SEEK ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FROM OR FOR THE CSU. AB
2395 IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND HAS
HAD NO OPPOSITION TO DATE. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA, I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR SERRANO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, THIS BILL ACTUALLY
DOES HAVE SOME OPPOSITION. AND
THIS THIS YEAR, WE FLOATED A CAL
VET FEE WAIVER PROGRAM, AND THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM USED
THIS VERY MONEY, WHICH THEY HAVE
AN OVERFLOW OF AS A REASON TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AND GET IT
KILLED. SO I DO OPPOSE THIS. AND
I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN ME IN DOING
SO. THANK YOU. SENATOR. SEE NO
OTHER MIX UP. SENATOR NEWMAN,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS MAKE A
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO THE
EDUCATION CODE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO THE
CSU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. I'LL GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NO. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. CHOBOQ Dð. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH BY RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN! MCGUIRE.
EBCLC. SEN. NEWMAN MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 168.
SENATOR ATKINS. SHE HAS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2696 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RENDON. AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2696 ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER
EMERITUS ANTHONY RENDON. THIS
BILL CLARIFIES THAT JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES
ESTABLISHED PURSUANT TO EXISTING
LAW MAY BRING AN ACTION IN COURT
AGAINST A DIRECT CONTRACTOR TO
ENFORCE LIABILITY FOR ANY UNPAID
EMPLOYEE WAGES OWED BY THE
CONTRACTOR. WAGE THEFT REMAINS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM IN OUR STATE,
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED SEVERAL
BILLS IN RECENT YEARS TO HELP
COMBAT THE PROBLEM. AB 2696 WILL
NOT AFFECT ANY CONTRACTOR THAT
IS NOT BREAKING THE LAW, AND IT
WILL HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR HONEST CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THE
LAW. THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY WITH 69 ZERO IN THE
VOTE COUNT. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I SEE NO MIX UP. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL
CALL ONCE. WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT
ON CALL. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN Ã
ALVARADO TO GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NÓ. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. CHOBOQ PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. ARABIA
SATO. NO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. BACK TO A FULL HOUSE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GIL
ASHBY. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. NÓ TROBO.
RUBIO. AYE EYES. EYES 32. NOES!
FIVE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR DURAZO IS UP WITH FIVE.
ITEM 169. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2754 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. RENDON. AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR. RAZO.
MADAM PRESIDENT. AB 2754 BY
SPEAKER EMERITUS. RENDON WILL
PROVIDE GREATER EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTION TO PORT DRAYAGE TRUCK
DRIVERS ACROSS THE STATE BY
ENSURING COMPANIES THAT CONTRACT
WITH THEM ARE HELD LIABLE FOR
ANY VIOLATIONS OF LABOR LAW.
THIS BILL WILL MOVE COMPANIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR CONTRACTS CAN
SATISFY LEGAL OBLIGATIONS TO
THEIR WORKERS. THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. SEEING NO
MICS UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
NO. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLEY NO. DODD. NO. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO. JOBO NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GLASER
HURTADO. AYE MCGUIRE. AYES 28.
NOES TEN. MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
THREE ARE. FILE ITEM 181, 184
AND 185. SENATOR EGGMAN HAS
FILED ITEM 181. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1111
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN. AN
ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 1111 AS A FARMER'S
DAUGHTER. KNOWING THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING THAT DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CONSUMER.
THIS ALLOWS CANNABIS FARMERS TO
BE ABLE TO SELL AT AUTHORIZED
EVENTS. CANNABIS DIRECTLY TO THE
SELLERS, BRINGING THE STOCK
RIGHT TO THE PERSON. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
THIS REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. GROVE. AYE. OR
DATO. NÓ. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
NO. NILO AYE. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
SEYARTO. SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB NØ.
WIENER WILK. ROTH. AYE STERN.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
BRADFORD GLAZER. GONZALEZ LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE OCHOA. B¢O
PORTANTINO. RUBIO SEYARTO.
SMALL. CUEVAS WIENER. WILK WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. BRADFORD. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. MCGUIRE. BOGUE
PORTANTINO. RUBIO. SEYARTO
SMALL. CUEVAS. WIENER WILK.
SENATOR EGGMAN MOVES THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 184.
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR WIENER,
FILE ITEM 184. HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1840 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE SENATOR
WIENER, PLEASE PROCEED. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1840 ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. THE BILL ENSURES THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR HOME OWNERSHIP ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY THE HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
FEDERAL RESTRICTIONS HAVE
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS FROM
HOUSING INITIATIVES, LIMITING
THEIR ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY AS
THEY SEEK TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S VIBRANT ECONOMY AND
COMMUNITY. AT THE STATE LEVEL,
IMMIGRATION STATUS CAN
COMPLICATE ACCESS TO HOME LOANS
AND HOMEOWNERSHIP ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS, POSING A SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIP IN AN ALREADY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT. THE
BILL ADDRESSES THIS DISPARITY
AND ENSURES THAT THE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
ARE ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE,
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ENSURING UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A
JUST, INCLUSIVE, FAIR, AND
BENEFICIAL POLICY FOR THE
SUCCESS AND VITALITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND THE
REASON I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS VERY SIMPLY, WE
CAN'T AFFORD IT. WE ARE ALREADY
IN BATTLING WITH DEFICITS EVERY
YEAR, YEAR OVER YEAR. AND SO TO
EXPAND A PROGRAM, WE ALREADY
HAVE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
EXPANDING A PROGRAM. AND THEN
WE'RE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SHORT
TO BE ABLE TO FUND IT. ANOTHER
REASON TO OPPOSE THIS IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT OF ELIGIBLE
CITIZENS RIGHT NOW THAT COULD
FULLY BENEFIT FROM THIS IF THEY
JUST HAD A DOWN PAYMENT, BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY DO HAVE THE INCOME
TO SUSTAIN A HOUSE PAYMENT ONCE
THEY HAVE THE DOWN PAYMENT.
RIGHT NOW, THIS PROGRAM IS
GIVING PEOPLE DOWN PAYMENTS, 20%
DOWN ON ON HOUSES THAT ARE
ARGUABLY AT THE AT THE PEAK OF
WHAT OUR HOUSING PRICES ARE
GOING TO BE. SO MANY OF US IN
THIS ROOM HAVE BEEN THROUGH
RECESSIONS, 2008 TO BE, FOR
EXAMPLE, HOUSING PRICES WENT
FROM $600,000 TO $300,000. IF
YOU'RE GIVING SOMEBODY 20% DOWN
ON A HOUSE AND THAT'S AT THE
MEDIAN INCOME THAT MEANS THEY
HAVE TO QUALIFY FOR A $500,000
LOAN AND IF WE DO NOT HAVE IF
WE'RE EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM
WITHOUT ANY REFERENCE TO, YOU
KNOW, IF SOMEBODY IS ACTUALLY A
CITIZEN HERE, I'M NOT SURE HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GO OUT AND
GET THAT PERSON QUALIFIED IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RECORD TO
GET QUALIFIED. AND WHAT IT DOES,
IS IT INCENTIVIZES MORTGAGE
BROKERS TO GIVE OUT MORTGAGES
BECAUSE THEY GET THEIRS. AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS LATER ON,
THE PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD THAT
PAYMENT. AND THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2008. EASY
MORTGAGES, EASY MORTGAGES. AND
PEOPLE WOUND UP LOSING THEIR
HOMES. THEY LOST THEIR ALL THEIR
FINANCIAL WHEREWITHAL AND THEY
WOUND UP HAVING A STAIN ON THEIR
THEIR FINANCIAL RECORD GOING
FORWARD. SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
REASONS NOT TO DO THIS AND NOT
TO DO THIS. NOW, WE CAN BE
GENEROUS, BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE MONEY TO BE GENEROUS, AND WE
ALSO HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN WE DO DO A
PROGRAM, WE DON'T LURE PEOPLE
INTO BEING BEING BASICALLY
HAVING A BANKRUPTCY OR A
FORECLOSURE ON THEIR FINANCIAL
RECORDS BECAUSE THEY'LL STAY
WITH THEM FOR A LONG TIME. THIS
IS MAKING PEOPLE THIS IS
INCENTIVIZING WHAT WE HAD IN
2008, WHERE THE LOANS WERE EASY
AND THEY DID. THEY KIND OF
OVERLOOKED A LOT OF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO HAVE A LOAN, A
$400,000 LOAN TAKES YOU AT LEAST
$2,500 IN TODAY'S FINANCIAL
INTEREST RATES, PLUS YOUR
MORTGAGE. I MEAN, PLUS YOUR,
YOUR YOUR PROPERTY TAXES, PLUS
THE INSURANCE AND ALL OF THAT.
YOU NEED TO MAKE FOR ABOUT
$12,500 A MONTH JUST TO AFFORD
PROBABLY SOME OF THE CHEAPEST
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A
RECIPE FOR FINANCIAL DISASTER
FOR INDIVIDUALS, ESPECIALLY
PEOPLE THAT REALLY CAN'T AFFORD
IT. I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR DASCHLE,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. DOING A GREAT JOB
TODAY. I RISE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB 1840. LOOK, WE HAVE VETERANS.
WE HAVE FOLKS OUT THERE. WE HAVE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE NOT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHO NEED
THESE SERVICES. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, I OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
SHOULD TAKE CARE OF THEM FIRST
BEFORE WE EXPAND IT OUT, ALONG
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MADE ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL STATE OF THIS STATE
RIGHT NOW, WHERE WE'RE AT
FINANCIALLY, THAT WE JUST CAN'T
AFFORD IT. AND I THINK IT'S
UNFAIR TO THE CITIZENS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE PUTTING OUT
MONEY THAT WE DON'T HAVE. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I OPPOSE AB 1840.
SENATOR, WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THIS HAS
A POTENTIAL IMPACT ON OUR
VETERANS WHEN IT COMES TO THEM.
AND THE MILITARY. I WILL ALWAYS
DEFEND IMPROVING THEIR LIVING
CONDITIONS, BENEFITS AND PAY TO
MANY OF THEM ARE HOMELESS AND ON
THE STREET, WHICH IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT. THESE FAMILIES NEEDS OUR
HELP. THE LATEST FIGURES FROM
HUD SHOWS 10,395 HOMELESS
VETERANS ON OUR STREETS. WHILE
THESE AREN'T THE ONLY PEOPLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM,
HAVING A PLACE TO CALL HOME
WOULD SPUR MANY OF THEM WHO
AREN'T ABLE TO WORK AND CAN'T
GET A JOB. AND MANY HOMELESS DO
ACTUALLY HAVE JOBS, BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE
BECAUSE IT'S SO EXPENSIVE TO
FIND A PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
THOSE WHO AREN'T HOMELESS, THEIR
RETIREMENT ISN'T NEARLY ENOUGH
TO EVEN BUY A HOUSE BARELY EVEN
ABLE TO PAY RENT. SO THIS
PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
AND RECONSIDERED AND NOT BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE EVERYBODY
ELSE. LET'S HELP OUR VETERANS
AND LET'S HELP OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION FIRST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR MIN,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, I HATE SEEING
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS BEING
TOSSED AROUND LIKE A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL IN OUR COUNTRY'S
POLITICAL DISCOURSE RIGHT NOW. I
HATE SEEING THE HEADLINES FROM
FOX NEWS ON DEMONIZING
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AS
SOMEONE WHO'S GROWN UP IN
CALIFORNIA WATCHING PRESIDENTS
OF BOTH REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC AFFILIATION IGNORE
THE PROBLEM OF PEOPLE COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT
DOCUMENTATION. TO ME, THIS IS A
MORAL ISSUE. IT IS AN ECONOMIC
ISSUE. BUT THE REALITY IS WE
HAVE OVER 10 MILLION PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT
DOCUMENTATION, AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. THEY HAVE
TO BUY HOMES. THERE ARE THINGS
WE HAVE TO DO, REALISTICALLY,
THAT BEING SAID, I JUST WILL BE
VOTING AGAINST THIS BILL TODAY
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS. I DID NOT
VOTE FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAM WHEN IT FIRST
CAME UP, BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
THE PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA WITH
OUR HOUSING IS THAT IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE, AND THAT IS A BIGGER
PROBLEM THAN DOWN PAYMENT OR
LACK OF DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT PROGRAM
AND PROGRAMS LIKE IT HAVE THE
EFFECT OF INCREASING OUR HOME
PRICES. SO I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING AGAINST THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT I HATE THE FACT THAT THIS
HAS BECOME ABOUT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, THAT WE HAVE
DEMONIZED PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
TRYING TO GET ALONG IN THIS
COUNTRY. SENATOR WAHAB, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, I JUST
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
AB 1840 PUTS INTO LAW EXISTING
PRACTICES AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT REQUIRE ANYONE
APPLYING FOR THESE TAXPAYER
FUNDED PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER OR
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, SPEAKING FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH A
FORECLOSURE CRISIS, THE BIG
BANKS WERE THE ONES THAT
BENEFITED DURING THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS. THEY KEPT THE PROPERTY,
AND THEY WERE ALSO STILL
ABSORBING FUNDS. AND WE CLAIM
THAT WE ARE FIXING THE PROBLEM
AND THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING PMIS THAT ARE
RIDICULOUSLY HIGH WHEN BANKS CAN
STILL, IF THEY FORECLOSE, STILL
KEEP THE ASSET, THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT PERFECT. I DON'T ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT'S PERFECT. THE FACT
THAT THEY RAN OUT OF MONEY
WITHIN, I THINK, 11 DAYS IN THIS
LAST CYCLE, IS STILL EVIDENCE
THAT HOME OWNERSHIP IS STILL
VERY DIFFICULT AND STILL VERY
MUCH SOUGHT AFTER BY REGULAR
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA, ONE OF
THE THINGS I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD BE A PROGRAM THAT IF YOU
ARE TAKING OUT A DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND GETTING SUPPORT
THAT THAT BE REINTEGRATED INTO
THE MAIN MORTGAGE, THE
INDIVIDUAL PAYS THAT MORTGAGE
AND THE STATE TAKES THEIR MONEY
FROM THAT OVERALL LOAN. THAT'S
THE WAY THAT THE MONEY CAN
CONTINUE TO FUNNEL INTO THIS
PROGRAM AND ACTUALLY HELP MORE
PEOPLE. BUT ONE OF THE REALITIES
OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS THAT WE
ARE NOT CURBING GREED. WE ARE
NOT CURBING THE FACT THAT,
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMPANIES AND INVESTMENT FIRMS
ARE PURCHASING ALL THE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES. WE DON'T HAVE DATA
OF WHO OWNS THE MAJORITY OF
HOMES. PEOPLE CLAIM THAT THEY'RE
SMALL LANDLORDS, BUT THEY OWN A
THOUSAND UNITS IN IN THE EAST
BAY ALONE, WE ARE CONSIDERING
SEEING CONSISTENT, ABUSES OF A
LOT OF PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPERS,
LIKE LIGHT TECH FUNDS THAT
EVICTED OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA, EVEN THOUGH THEY
RECEIVED THESE FUNDS. I WILL SAY
THAT THERE IS PLENTY OF PROBLEMS
WITH A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OUT THERE, BUT
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TODAY IS NOT THE
PROBLEM. SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR CABALLERO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
DIDN'T INTEND TO SPEAK ON THIS
TODAY, BUT I REALLY WANT TO
BRING OUR EYES BACK TO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES, BECAUSE WE CAN'T
SOLVE ALL OF OUR HOUSING
PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL. AND
THIS BILL DOESN'T EVEN ATTEMPT
TO DO THAT. HOMELESSNESS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS SO HUGE. MENTAL
HEALTH, ADDICTION. A BILL AWAY
FROM INSOLVENCY, THAT ISSUE,
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH FOR YEARS TO COME.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS PROGRAM AND YOU
HAVE TO WORK IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM AND
TO BE ELIGIBLE. AND IF YOU'RE
WORKING IT MEANS YOU'VE GOT
YOU'RE USING AN ITIN. IF YOU'RE
NOT HERE, AS A US CITIZEN OR AS
A GREEN CARD, GREEN CARD HOLDER.
AND SO ALL THIS DOES IS PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO GET IN
LINE. IF YOU CAN AFFORD TO BUY A
HOUSE. AND MANY OF YOU LIVE IN
DISTRICTS WHERE A HOUSE IS
UNAFFORDABLE FOR ANYBODY, THAT
IS, NOT A WEALTHY PERSON. BUT IN
MY DISTRICT, HOMES ARE STILL
AVAILABLE. YOU CAN STILL BUY
PROPERTY IF YOU'RE A WORKING
FAMILY AND MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES HAVE TWO, THREE AND
FOUR PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE
HOUSEHOLD, THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS, MANY OF WHOM WERE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS DURING THE
COVID CRISIS, TO BE ABLE TO GET
IN LINE AND HOPEFULLY BUY THEIR
FIRST HOME. IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
EASY. THE PROGRAM WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED IMMEDIATELY, BUT
WE NEED TO PUT MORE MONEY INTO
THE PROGRAM. IT'S THE BEST WAY
TO PASS ON YOUR WEALTH TO YOUR
KIDS AND IT'S THE DREAM.
EVERYBODY HAS, WHICH IS TO HAVE
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH TO
LEAVE SOMETHING, EVEN IF IT'S A
PIECE OF PROPERTY THAT PEOPLE
CAN CAN CALL THEIR OWN. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY, SEEING NO OTHER MICS UP.
SENATOR SENATOR OKOBO, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE COMING TO
THE TO THE SENATE, I WAS, I
WORKED AS A REALTOR AND
UNDERSTANDING THIS PROGRAM IS
KNOWING THAT IT WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND THE FUNDS
WERE LITERALLY OUT WITHIN THE
FIRST 11 DAYS WAS STATED. I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
AND THE REASON I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY IS
BECAUSE IT REALLY, I FIND IT TO
BE, NOT INTENTIONALLY, OF
COURSE, BUT IT IS DISRESPECTFUL
TO THE 1 MILLION IMMIGRANTS THAT
COME HERE DOCUMENTED WHO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND ACTUALLY
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS TO COME
TO THIS COUNTRY LEGALLY THAT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE A HOME. I HAVE
WE HAD BROKERS, WE HAD AGENTS,
WE HAD FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
ACTUALLY CAME HERE LEGALLY AND
ARE NOW ABLE TO PURCHASE A HOME.
BUT IF WE CONTINUE TO CREATE A
SYSTEM IN WHICH WE REWARD, YOU
KNOW, AND THIS IS NOT SAYING
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING AND
WAITING FOR THE PROCESS, THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS RIGHT NOW IN
THE UNITED STATES IS COMPLETELY
APPALLING. IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
WHERE IT SHOULD BE. THAT NEEDS
TO BE FIXED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE WAITING
LITERALLY 20 YEARS TO ACTUALLY
GET THEIR, THEIR, THEIR
CITIZENSHIP. BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND, RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE'RE
FACING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE, YOU KNOW, AS THE US AS A
WHOLE, 1 MILLION IMMIGRANTS THAT
COME HERE LEGALLY, THAT ARE
ACTUALLY MANY OF THEM ARE HOPING
TO GET ASSISTANCE TO PURCHASE A
HOME. THIS PARTICULAR BILL, WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE ACTUALLY
DISENFRANCHIZES AND DISRESPECTS
THOSE WHO HAVE ACTUALLY GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND ARE
READY TO PURCHASE A HOME, OR
WOULD LIKE TO PURCHASE A HOME.
IT DISENFRANCHIZES AND TAKES
AWAY THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR, YOU
KNOW, AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY, VETERANS WHO NEED
ASSISTANCE IN ORDER TO PURCHASE
WHO ARE YOU KNOW, WE HEAR FROM
OUR DISTRICT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
HOW THEY'RE NOT BEING FULLY,
ASSISTED WITH SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED. IT TAKES AWAY FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, ON THE LOWER
INCOME WHO NEED ASSISTANCE THAT
DON'T HAVE PARENTS TO HELP THEM
WITH A DOWN PAYMENT, IN THIS
AREA. SO, THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT WE TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT ARE ACTUALLY MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHO NEED ASSISTANCE
AND ARE READY AND QUALIFIED TO
BE ABLE TO, TO PURCHASE A HOME.
I DO DISAGREE WITH MY WITH THE
COMMENTS IN WHICH, YOU KNOW, IT
WAS IMPLIED THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE APPLYING FOR THIS PROGRAM
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED WOULD NOT
BE FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE. YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOU'RE
FINANCIALLY ABLE AND CAPABLE TO
GET A LOAN IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
FOR THIS PROGRAM. SO I DO
DISAGREE ON THAT, ON THAT, ON
THAT POINT. THAT WAS MADE. BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD CREATE
SYSTEMS, ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AND WE HAVE,
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE DO
RESPECT. THOSE THAT ARE, GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS LEGALLY AND,
AND RESPONSIBLY IN, IN OUR
SYSTEM, AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I
WILL BE, OPPOSING THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
BECAUSE WE KEEP MENTIONING
VETERANS, THREE VETERANS ARE UP
NEXT TO TALK ON THEIR
EXPERIENCES. SENATOR EGGMAN,
YOU'RE FIRST. OH. THANK YOU.
AGAIN, TO TAKE IT BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM, MERCED. LET'S
LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
EXPANDING AN ALREADY EXISTING
PROGRAM, NOT JUST INVITING
PEOPLE IN, BUT TO EXPANDING IT.
THAT IMMIGRATION STATUS DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU MEET ALL THE OTHER
QUALIFICATIONS. AND I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF VETERANS. BUT I WILL
SAY LIKE THIS IS NOT A PIE. IT'S
NOT LIKE LESS FOR OTHERS. AND
VETERANS HAVE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO US BECAUSE WE
SERVED TO BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE
HOUSE LOANS. SO I APPRECIATE ALL
THE SUPPORT, BUT WE'RE DOING
OKAY. THANKS, SEN. NEWMAN I LET
ME JUST ADD TO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON, BUT
ALSO MY COLLEAGUE FROM MERCED.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A CLARIFICATION
BILL. THIS THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM OR
SUBSTANTIALLY EXPAND AN EXISTING
PROGRAM. WHAT IT DOES IS IT
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS AMBIGUITY IN
THE EXISTING REGULATION. AND
MANY BUYERS HAVE RECEIVED
CONFLICTING INFORMATION. THE
DREAM FOR ALL PROGRAM STATES
THAT BORROWER ELIGIBILITY IS
LIMITED TO EITHER A CITIZEN OR
OTHER NATIONAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, OR A QUALIFIED ALIEN, AS
DEFINED IN EIGHT U.S.C. SECTION
1641. THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION
AS TO WHO WAS ELIGIBLE, BUT ALL
THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE ARE
ACTUALLY ALIENS IN GOOD STANDING
OR UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS IN
GOOD STANDING WHO OTHERWISE
MIGHT BE DETERRED FROM APPLYING
FOR A LOAN. AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE MAXIMUM
VALUE OF THIS LOAN IS 150,000 AT
THE MOST, AND SO WE ARE NOT
PUTTING PROSPECTIVE BUYERS IN IN
A IN A JEOPARDIZED SITUATION.
AND THEY ARE STILL SUBJECT TO
ALL OF THE OTHER CREDIT
WORTHINESS CHECKS. AND SO I URGE
A YES VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I I KNOW WE ALL COME
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS, 30
YEARS IN BUSINESS IN THIS STATE,
AND I SEE, SOME OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND I THINK YOU
GUYS SEE TO THE INFLATION, THE
THINGS THAT GO ON IN THE WORLD.
AND I THINK IF WE GO BACK TO THE
ROOT CAUSE, THAT'S WHAT WE AS
BUSINESS OWNERS DO, WE DON'T TRY
TO PUT BAND-AIDS ON THINGS. WE
GO BACK TO WHAT THE ROOT CAUSE
IS, WHAT'S ESCALATING AND
INJURY, WHAT'S ESCALATING, THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS. THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. SO IF YOU GO
BACK TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
COST OF HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, IT'S THE POLICIES
THAT ARE PASSED OUT OF THIS
BUILDING WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, IF YOU GO BACK TO THE ROOT
CAUSES OF CHILD CARE, WE
INCREASE THE COST OF CHILD CARE,
THEN WE SUBSIDIZE CHILD CARE FOR
THOSE OUT OF OUR GENERAL FUND
BUDGET TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE
CHILD CARE, WHICH WAS THE REASON
A POLICY WAS PUT IN PLACE. WE
LOOK AT THE COST OF UTILITIES.
IF YOU LOOK AT ARIZONA, THEY PAY
$300 A MONTH WHERE THE SAME
KILOWATTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LIKE $1,600 A MONTH. THOSE ARE
ALL ROOT CAUSES OF POLICIES. OUT
OF THIS BUILDING, PEOPLE COULD
AFFORD HOMES. WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THE HOUSING SITUATION OR THE
HOMELESS SITUATION IF THE
POLICIES DIDN'T INFLATE THE COST
OF HOUSING. THIS BILL, SIMILAR
TO ALL THE OTHER ONES I JUST
MENTIONED, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COST OF FUEL, AGAIN, YOU GUYS
HATE, I FEEL LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD, BUT WE IMPORT FUEL,
WHICH CREATES A COST TO BRING
THAT FUEL TEST INSTEAD OF
PRODUCING IT HERE, WHICH RAISES
THE COST OF FUEL, THE TAX
INCREASES THAT WE HAVE EVERY
YEAR INTO PERPETUITY WITH BILLS
AND POLICIES THAT ARE PASSED OUT
HERE, INCREASE THE COST OF FUEL,
AND THEN WE SUBSIDIZE THE COST
OF FUEL. WE SUBSIDIZE THE COST
OF UTILITIES, WHICH AFFECTS OUR
GENERAL FUND BUDGET. THIS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE'RE DEBATING IS
THE SAME THING. WE POLICIES OUT
OF THIS BUILDING INCREASE THE
COST OF HOUSING. AND THEN WE
SUBSIDIZE THAT. IN THIS CASE,
IT'S $150,000 LOAN PROGRAM. SO
EVEN IF YOU GO WITH THE WITH THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS OR
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS OR
VETERANS OR NØ VETERANS, YOU'RE
SUBSIDIZING A PROGRAM WHICH
CREATED WHICH POLICIES OUT OF
THIS BUILDING, INCREASE THE COST
OF US PURCHASING HOMES, WHICH
CREATED A PROBLEM OF HOUSING IN
OUR STATE. SO I GUESS WE COULD
JUST GO BACK TO THE ROOT CAUSE.
AND INSTEAD OF SUBSIDIZING ALL
THESE PROGRAMS, WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE THE BILLS THAT CAUSE
THESE THE COST OF THESE
INCREASES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE FIRST PLACE. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT
YOU KNOW, WE ARE IN A COMPLETE
BUDGET DEFICIT AND, YOU KNOW,
SUBSIDIZING HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT HERE, LEGALLY IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING. I DO I DO NOT SUPPORT
THAT IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE SO
MANY AMERICANS STANDING IN LINE
WAITING FOR A HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN UP, I KNOW
THAT INTEREST RATES HAVE GONE
UP. MY KIDS ARE PAYING 7%
INTEREST ON A NEW HOUSE THEY
JUST BOUGHT. THAT'S AGAIN, THE
COST OF POLICIES ARE. THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THAT IS POLICIES COMING
OUT OF THIS BUILDING BUILDING
AND THE FEDERAL BUILDING. SO I
GET IT. BUT I STAND UP AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS. AND WE SHOULD ADDRESS
POLICIES THAT INCREASE COST,
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO PUT
BAND-AIDS ON IT AND FUND AND
SUBSIDIZE PROGRAMS THAT JUST
AREN'T WORKING. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR DOLE,
YOU'RE ONCE AGAIN RECOGNIZED. I
JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH THE BODY
THAT I WAS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL HOMEBUYERS,
PROGRAM NATIONAL, THE LARGEST,
DOWN SYSTEM OF PAYMENT IN THE
NATION, WHEN I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR, I WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT THE FACT THAT THIS IS NOT
THAT THIS IS CAL HFA. SO THIS IS
STATE MONIES THAT GOES INTO THIS
PROGRAM. SO MAKE NO MISTAKE,
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS THAT ARE TAX EXEMPT
BONDS PUT UP BY CORPORATIONS
THAT ARE DONE NATIONALLY AND IN
THE STATE, BUT THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM WHICH IS
GOING TO AFFECT OUR BUDGET. I
WANT THE RECORD TO REFLECT THAT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. I SEE NO
FURTHER MIX UP. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU MAY CLOSE, THIS HAS BEEN AN
INTERESTING DEBATE. IT'S, WHERE
FOX NEWS, ANTI-IMMIGRATION
PROPAGANDA COLLIDES WITH HOUSING
POLICY, JUST TO START OUT WITH,
AS THE FORMER LONG TIME CHAIR OF
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE,
IMMIGRATION IS NOT WHAT'S
CAUSING OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
WHAT'S CAUSING OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HOMES. PERIOD. I AGREE
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
PRESIDENT OBAMA ON THAT. WE NEED
TO BUILD A LOT MORE HOMES. AND
THANK YOU TO THOSE COLLEAGUES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY SUPPORTED OUR EFFORTS
TO MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD NEW
HOMES. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS, NOT
HARMING IMMIGRANTS OR PREVENTING
IMMIGRANTS FROM BUYING HOMES,
BUT ON THE ACTUAL BILL, YOU KNOW,
WE CAN YOU CAN LOVE OR HATE OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM. I THINK IT'S
COMPLETELY BROKEN. BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT WE HAVE MORE
THAN 10 MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WITHOUT DOCUMENTS WHO
ARE WORKING, WHO ARE PAYING
TAXES, WHOSE KIDS ARE IN OUR
SCHOOLS, WHO ARE STARTING
BUSINESSES, WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY, OFTEN FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS, WHEN MY GREAT
GRANDPARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY FLEEING
ANTI-JEWISH VIOLENCE IN EASTERN
EUROPE AND RUSSIA, THEY WERE
ABLE TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND
HAVE DOCUMENTS AND BECOME
DOCUMENTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND PAY TAXES AND WORK
AND HAVE CHILDREN AND DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT FAMILIES TO
BE ABLE TO DO. BUT THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM WAS VERY
DIFFERENT THEN. NOW WE HAVE
PEOPLE FLEEING VIOLENCE, WHETHER
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA OR
ELSEWHERE, AND WHO ARE RISKING
THEIR FAMILIES LIVES TO MAKE THE
JOURNEY TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY,
WHETHER LAST YEAR OR TEN YEARS
AGO, PUTTING THEIR FAMILIES
LIVES IN RISK IN ORDER TO COME
TO THIS COUNTRY TO MAKE A BETTER
LIVES FOR THEMSELVES, WHICH IN
MY BOOK ARE EXACTLY THE KIND OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU WANT IN YOUR
COMMUNITY, PEOPLE WHO ARE SO
THEY WANT TO BE HERE. THESE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME OF THE BEST
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY,
WORKING HARD AND APPRECIATING
THIS COUNTRY EVERY DAY OF THE
WEEK. AND THEY ARE BEING TREATED
LIKE GARBAGE, AND NOT JUST BY
FOX NEWS, BY THE POLICIES WE PUT
IN PLACE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
THESE ARE FOLKS IN TERMS OF THIS
BILL WHO HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS OR TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS. THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING AND
PAYING TAXES. AND YES, THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BUY A HOME.
THEY SHOULD BE PART OF THIS
PROGRAM. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE SPEER. NO. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. NO DODD. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLASER. GONZALEZ.
AYE AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMON.
AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
NO NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO.
NO. TROBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. NO SEN. WIENER. MOVES A
CALL. SENATOR HURTADO, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 185. I'M READY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1864 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. AN ACT RELATING TO
PESTICIDES. SENATOR HURTADO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY TO PRESENT AB
1864, AN EASY. I VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT HELPS PROTECT
CHILDREN, THOSE THAT ARE
ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
DAYCARES IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTED BY A
REGULATION THAT RESTRICTS THE
MOST DROUGHT PRONE AGRICULTURAL
PESTICIDE APPLICATIONS DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY FROM 6 A.M. TO 6
P.M. MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY IN
PRACTICE, THIS REGULATION IS
OFTEN UNENFORCEABLE, WHILE
NOTICES OF INTENT MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS BEFORE USING
CLASSIFIED PESTICIDES. OFTEN THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IS NOT
SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE METHOD
TRIGGERED THESE PROTECTIONS. AB
1864 SEEKS TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
BY REQUIRING ANNUAL PERMITS TO
INCLUDE METHOD OF APPLICATION
AND SPECIFIC SITE IDENTIFICATION
FOR USE, REPORTS TO INCLUDE
METHOD AND TIMING OF
APPLICATION. THIS BILL ALSO
ENSURES EQUITY BY EXTENDING THE
SAME PROTECTIONS TO CHILDREN,
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF IN
PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND DAYCARES ALREADY
AFFORD ARE AFFORDED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR. WE ARE
ALL TALKED OUT. I SEE NO MICS
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN Ã ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NO. NILO OCHOA.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO I RA.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER.
AYE. A SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL DALLEY. NO. JONES
MCGUIRE. NILO. AYE BOGUE.
CIERTO. NO. AYES 32. NOS. FOR
THE MEASURE. PASSES. NEXT THREE
WE HAVE ON DECK IS 186 FOR ITEM
191 AND FILE ITEM 209. SENATOR
STERN HAS BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING. HE IS READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1889
BY SEMINAR MEMBER. FRIEDMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MADAM PRESIDENT, THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER AND
MINIMIZE IMPACTS TO WILDLIFE
MOVEMENT AND EMBRACE HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY AS PART OF THEIR
CONSERVATION ELEMENT IN THEIR
NEXT GENERAL PLAN UPDATE. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS ARE
GETTING AHEAD OF THESE ISSUES
THAT YOU YOU FACE IN THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE. WE
KNOW THERE'S INCREASING ROAD
SAFETY ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE WHO DON'T PLAN AHEAD. AND
WE'RE ALSO LOSING HABITAT AND
ALARMING RATE IN THIS STATE.
OPEN SPACE AND HABITATS FOR
EVERYBODY. AND THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION. SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. I'M SEEING NO MIX
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I. ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO. HURTADO I
JONES. LAIRD I LIMÓN I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN. NILO NO JOBO. NO PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER, I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER I
JONES, MCGUIRE NGUYEN NÓ AYES
31. NO SEVEN MEASURE PASSES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
191. SENATOR WAHAB IS READY.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE SECRETARY HAS TO
READ. SORRY. ASSEMBLY BILL 2106
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN
ACT RELATING TO PROBATION.
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
SUPPORT, SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, CHAIR OF PUBLIC
SAFETY ON THE ASSEMBLY, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 20 106, WHICH
PROVIDES CALIFORNIANS WITH
PREVIOUS DRUG CONVICTIONS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAINTAIN
SOBRIETY AND RETURN TO SOCIETY
WITH SUPPORTIVE FACILITIES,
PROGRAMS AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES
FOR THEIR CONDITIONS AND LIFE
SITUATIONS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I
SEE NO MIKE. SUP, SECRETARY?
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. AYE DODD. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE. MILO AYE. AYE EBCLC.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY AYE. DODD AYE. JONES
MCGUIRE. CHIRLA. BOGUE WILK. AYE
AYES 37. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR ROTH HAS FILED
ITEM 209 AND ENJOYS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1788 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THE BILL
ALLOWS COUNTIES TO OPT IN TO
ESTABLISH MENTAL HEALTH
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAMS
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS. AS FOR AN
I VOTE PHENOMENAL NO MIX UP,
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT THREE
ON DECK ARE FILE ITEM 212, 214,
AND 216. SENATOR DODD, YOU'RE
FOR THE BILL. ARE YOU PREPARED?
IS SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2048 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG. AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2048 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. IT IS ONE
OF 12 BILLS FROM THE CALL TO
ACTION BILL PACKAGE TO PRODUCE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON
CAMPUS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE ANY DISCUSSION. THIS
ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM 214 AB 2132.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2132 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
AN ACT TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I'M
PRESENTING AB 2132 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WILL REQUIRE
PRIMARY CARE CLINICS TO OFFER
TUBERCULOSIS SCREENINGS TO ADULT
PATIENTS. EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT RELEASED NEW DATA
SHOWING A 19% INCREASE IN NEW TB
DIAGNOSES IN THE COUNTY. DESPITE
THE HIGH PREVALENCE OF TB, MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT EVER UNDERGO A
RISK ASSESSMENT OR SCREENING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. NO
DISCUSSION. THIS ITEM IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. I SEE NO OBJECTION. AYES
38 NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR DODD ONCE AGAIN. MIGHT
AS WELL STAY STANDING UP. YOU
HAVE FILE ITEM 216. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2326
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR DODD. MADAM PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT 2220
2326 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ.
WITH THIS BILL, WE'RE MAKING A
PATHWAY FORWARD TO PARTNER WITH
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
ASSIST IN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
FREE FROM SEXUAL DISCRIMINATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. NO
DISCUSSION, NO DEBATE ITEM IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE ITEM 107,
FAR ITEM 217 AND FAR FILE. ITEM
225. SENATOR MENGIBAR IS NOT
READY. THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THE ASSEMBLY BILL 1977 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
SENATOR. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE
ITEM 107 AB 1977 WOULD PROHIBIT
A HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN FROM
REQUIRING AN ENROLLEE PREVIOUSLY
DIAGNOSED WITH PERVASIVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISORDER OR AUTISM
FROM NEEDING TO RECEIVE A NEW
BEHAVIORAL DIAGNOSIS TO MAINTAIN
COVERAGE FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR A VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL? AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. TÍNH. IT'S FALL.
ITEM 217. ARE WE? OKAY FOR
SENATOR NAVARRO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2389
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL. AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR RIVERA, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. AB 2389. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL WILL REQUIRE THAT IF
AN EMPLOYEE OF A BAR OR
NIGHTCLUB IS MADE AWARE THAT A
PATRON HAS BEEN OR BELIEVES TO
HAVE BEEN ROOFIED, THE EMPLOYEE
OF THE ESTABLISHMENT CAN TAKE
TWO ACTIONS CONTACT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR MEDICAL SERVICES,
AND TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY, FOLLOW THE INSTRUCTIONS
GIVEN BY THAT MEDICAL OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL OVER THE
PHONE AND MONITOR THE DRUGGED
INDIVIDUAL UNTIL THESE SERVICES
ARRIVE. RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 38. NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ON DECK IS GOING TO BE FILE
ITEM 225 SOMETHING. SENATOR
GLAZER IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3177
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WENDY CARRILLO, ASSEMBLY BILL
3177 ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES ON
SPOT WIDENING DEDICATIONS, A
PRACTICE IN WHICH DEVELOPERS
CEDE A PORTION OF THEIR LAND
ADJACENT TO A ROADWAY TO WIDEN
IT WITHOUT COMPENSATION. SPOT
WIDENING REQUIREMENTS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE HOUSING
COSTS, ADDING BETWEEN 10 AND
$50,000 PER HOUSING UNIT,
AMOUNTING TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
PROJECT. THIS PRACTICE IS DONE
IN A HANDFUL OF JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, ALL TOO
OFTEN RESULTING IN ROADS THAT
ESSENTIALLY ZIGZAG PARCEL BY
PARCEL FAILING TO MEET THE
INTENDED PURPOSE. THE BILL HAS
SOME REFERENCE TO TRANSIT
STATIONS AND TRANSIT PRIORITY
AREAS. WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I'M SEEING
NO DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL NØ.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALI. NÓ DODD. AYE. Ó. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NO. NILO NO. DROBO. NO. PODIUM
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES.
MCGUIRE WILK.
AYES 30. NØ SEVEN. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR STERN IS CLOSE
BEHIND. SENATOR DODD HERE. HE
HAS FIVE. ITEM 227. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2684
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT AND
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR STERN, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES
WHEN THEY'RE UPDATING THEIR
LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS OR
SAFETY ELEMENTS TO LOOK AT HOW
HOT IT'S GETTING. IT'S A PRETTY
SIMPLE BILL. STRATEGIC PLANNING.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE DYING FROM THE
HEAT IN RECORD NUMBERS. SO WE
THINK THIS WILL IMPROVE THE
ABILITY TO GET FEDERAL FUNDING
AND MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I AM SEEING
NO MICS UP. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALL RIGHT.
I VOTED NO. ARCHULETA. I ASHBY,
I ATKINS, I BECKER, I BLAKESBURG,
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALI NØ DODD. TERRAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO HURTADO I JONES. LAIRD I
LEMON I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO NILO NO
JOBO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD
GLAZER. JONES MCGUIRE. OKOBOJI
ROTH. AYES 27 NØ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES THE NEXT THREE ON DECK
ARE FIVE. ITEM TWO, TWO, EIGHT,
TWO, THREE, FIVE AND 240.
SENATOR LIMON HAS THE NEXT TWO.
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 81 BY
SOME MEMBER. RAMOS. AN ACT
RELATING TO INDIAN CHILDREN AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. CERTAIN
LIMON. THANK YOU. MEMBERS AB 81
WOULD CODIFY SECTIONS OF THE
FEDERAL INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
LAW INFO STRENGTHENING
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CHILDREN. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THIS NEEDS 27 VOTES.
ANY DISCUSSION? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO.
PADILLA. OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE UMBERG. I. WAHAB AYE. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY
JONES. LAIRD. AYE MCGUIRE. MILO.
AYES 36. ON THE URGENCY. AYES
36. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SECTOR-LIMÓN HAS FIREARM 235.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3283 BY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL ACTIONS. SENATOR LYMAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 3283 BY ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON CLAIMS OF
EXEMPTION. THIS BILL PROPOSES A
MINOR PROCEDURAL FIX TO A
CRITICAL ISSUE IN DEBT
COLLECTION CASES. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT APPEARING FOR A
CLAIM OF EXEMPTION HEARING DOES
NOT EQUATE TO CONSENTING TO THE
COURT'S JURISDICTION FOR THE
ENTIRE CASE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I SEE NO MIKES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DAWLEY. NO. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. JOBO NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE. NO JONES.
NO MAGUIRE. PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MAGUIRE.
PADILLA. AYE AYES 39. NOES NINE.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR DURAZZO,
TIED WITH SENATOR STERN, HAS
FIRED HIM 240. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2347 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT
RELATING TO SUMMARY PROCEEDINGS.
SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AB 2347 WILL
MAKE TWO UPDATES TO LANDLORD
TENANT LAW. EXTEND THE TIME FOR
A TENANT TO RESPOND TO A SUMMONS
BY FIVE ADDITIONAL DAYS AND
CODIFY A TIMELINE FOR DEMURS AND
MOTIONS TO STRIKE HEARINGS. THE
DANGER BEHIND DETERMINING
SOMETHING AS CRITICAL AS SHELTER
ON SUCH A QUICK TIMELINE IS THAT
DUE PROCESS CAN EASILY BE
COMPROMISED FOR LOW INCOME
TENANTS THAT MAKE UP THE VAST
MAJORITY OF EVICTION CASE
DEFENDANTS, THE DIFFICULTY IS
EXACERBATED DECIPHERING THE
LEGAL FORMS IS COMPLEX.
PROCEDURALLY TENANTS IN MOST
JURISDICTIONS TRAVEL TO THE
COURTHOUSE, WAIT IN LINE, FILL
OUT FORMS TO DO SO, MOST TENANTS
HAVE TO MISS WORK, AND IF THEY
HAVE CHILDREN, ARRANGE FOR
CHILDCARE. IF THE FIVE DAYS RUN
OUT BEFORE THE TENANT FILES A
RESPONSE, THE LANDLORD CAN GET A
DEFAULT JUDGMENT AGAINST THE
TENANT AND THEY MAY LOSE THE
CASE WITHOUT EVER GETTING THEIR
DAY IN COURT, EVEN IF THEY HAVE
A MERITORIOUS DEFENSE TO THE
EVICTION. THE PURPOSE BEHIND THE
SUMMARY NATURE OF EVICTION
PROCEEDINGS IS TO ENABLE
LANDLORDS TO RECOVER POSSESSION
OF THEIR RENTAL PROPERTY
RELATIVELY QUICKLY, AND WITH
FEEDBACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, AB 1082
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NÓ. MIKE SUP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL NÓ.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NÓ. DODD
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. WAYNE. NO MILO. NO JABO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BLAKE. SPEAR DODD. GLAZER
MCGUIRE. MIN NEWMAN. OKUBO. NO
PORTANTINO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE AYES 23. NOES NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. COLLEAGUES.
BECAUSE TODAY WE'RE IN HERE, AND
IT'S A MOSTLY DRY DAY. WE HAVE
SOME SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBERS. OUR SPECIAL SERVICES
MEMBERS ARE JOINING US TODAY. IF
WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THEM FOR
THEIR HARD WORK.
WE ARE BACK IN BUSINESS NO MORE
FUN. THE NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE
FILED. ITEM 243, 244 AND 248
SEN. TIE WAS SHORT LIVED. SEN
STERN IS BACK UP. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ BILL 2522 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO,
AN ACT RELATING TO AIR
DISTRICTS. SENATOR STERN HAS THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WILL UPDATE
COMPENSATION LIMITS FOR BOARD
MEMBERS OF AIR DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THEY WERE
LAST SET IN THE 1980S. THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE AN INCREASE OF
UP TO $200 PER DAY FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT AND UNDERAPPRECIATED
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. SEEING NO MIX UP,
WE ARE ABOUT TO TAKE ROLL ON
FINAL ITEM 243. WE'RE TAKING
ROLL. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ELLEN HI. ALDER GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA HI, ASHBY. ATKINS HI,
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEAR HI,
BRADFORD. CABALLERO HI. CORTEZ
HI. DALLEY. NÓ DODD. DURAZO. HI
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER NO. GONZALEZ
HI. GROVE NO. HURTADO. HI JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN I
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO.
JOBO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY
AYE. BECKER AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
DODD MCGUIRE. OKOBO NO.
PORTANTINO. NO LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
DODD AYE. MCGUIRE. AYES 28. NOES
11. THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
LEMON, BACK IN THE GAME. SHE HAS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. I'M AT THREE. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3059 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
MILK. SENATOR LEMON. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS AB
3059 WILL IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR PREMATURE INFANTS.
THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PASTEURIZED
DONOR HUMAN MILK, KNOWN AS DONOR
MILK, IS A BASIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICE UNDER COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS. DONOR MILK IS A COVERED
BENEFIT UNDER MEDI-CAL, BUT
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT CLEARLY
DEFINE IT IS A COVERED BENEFIT
UNDER COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS,
AB 3059 WOULD ENSURE PARITY AND
REQUIRE THAT ALL COMMERCIAL
HEALTH PLANS PROVIDE COVERAGE
FOR MEDICALLY NECESSARY DONOR
MILK. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR, NO
MIX UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN Ã ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY DODD. AYE
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON AYE. MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO AYE. AKOBO. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. DALI HURTADO. AYE. JONES
MCGUIRE. SATO WILK. AYE. AYES
36. NØ. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR BECKER, YOU HAVE ITEM
248. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2368 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. PETRIE-NORRIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, PLEASED
TO PRESENT THIS BILL BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS ON THE
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF ELECTRIC
SYSTEM RELIABILITY. THIS BILL
APPROACHES RELIABILITY IN A
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER, INCLUDING
DIRECTING THE CPUC TO REGULARLY
CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT OF MIDTERM
RELIABILITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE NÓ. MIKE SUP,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. TROBERG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG ABRAHAM.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. GROVE AYE.
MCGUIRE AYES 39. NÓ. ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES THE. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM TWO,
5256 AND 258. SEN CUEVAS IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3063 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I AM HERE TO PRESENT
AB 3063, WHICH WOULD CLARIFY
THAT THE ADDITION OF A FLAVORING
AGENT TO ENHANCE THE TASTE OF A
PRESCRIPTION DOES NOT CONSTITUTE
COMPOUNDING. SINCE NOVEMBER 1ST
OF 2023, THE NUMBER OF
PHARMACIES PROVIDING FLAVORING
DROP FROM 3100 TO ROUGHLY 30
TOTAL. A 99.5% REDUCTION IN
ACCESS TO THE SERVICE LITERALLY
OVERNIGHT. THIS MEASURE WILL
AFFIRM EXISTING STANDARDS AND
PRACTICES AT PHARMACIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, BRINGING THE
PRACTICE OF FLAVORING BACK TO
INDEPENDENT AND RETAIL
PHARMACIES, THEREBY MAKING IT
EASIER FOR PARENTS AND CHILDREN
AND THOSE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICINE. THEY WILL ACTUALLY
TAKE. THIS MEASURE IS CRITICAL
TO ENSURING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
REFLECTS AN URGENCY CAUSE. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THIS ITEM REQUIRES 27 VOTES AND
IT'S ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION ON THE
URGENCY? AYES 39. NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR ALLEN,
HE'S ROCKING AND HE'S ROLLING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. FILE
ITEM 256. ASSEMBLY BILL 2951 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
SENATOR ALLEN. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. THIS BILL DELAYS
IMPLEMENTATION OF PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION UPDATING THE PROCESS
FOR NOTIFYING, NOTIFYING VOTERS
OF A CANCELLATION OF
REGISTRATION TO PROVIDE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WITH
ADDITIONAL TIME TO UPDATE THE
SYSTEM. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SENATOR ALLEN ROAD RECORD. ANY
DISCUSSION? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GILL NO. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALY NÓ DODD I D'ORAZIO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO. HURTADO I JONES. NO
LAIRD I LEMON. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
I MEAN, I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO.
NILO MUCHO EBCLC. NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO. NO. SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB. WIENER
I WILK. NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
NILO. WAHAB I.
SENATOR ALLEN MOVES THE CALL
SENATOR ROTH HAS FILED. I'M 258.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2373 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RENDON. AN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILE HOMES. SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS
BILL PROTECTS MOBILE HOME
TENANTS FROM BEING EVICTED OR
HAVING THEIR RENT INCREASED BY A
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNER WHO DOES
NOT HAVE AN UP TO DATE PERMIT OF
OPERATION. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE. FANTASTIC. SENATOR,
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE. ANY
DISCUSSION? NONE. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS LIMON IS
IN THE LOUNGE.
IT IS RUINED. NO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI. ALL RIGHT. AGO.
HI, ARCHULETA. HI, ASHBY. HI
ATKINS. HI, BECKER. I BLAKE
SPEER. I BRADFORD CABALLERO I
CORTEZ. HI. DAWLEY. HI. DODD HI.
DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES. HI, LAIRD. HI LIMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MEN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I NILO I JACOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SEYARTO I SKINNER I
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I SCHWAB
I WIENER I WILK I SENATOR ROTH
MOVES A CALL. THE NEXT THREE ARE
ON DECK OR FILE ITEM TWO SIX.
YEAH FIVE ITEM. THE NEXT ONE UP
IS FILE ITEM 265. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2527
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER B¢O
BAUER-KAHAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
INCARCERATION. SENATOR, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I PRESENT AB 2527
SUPPORTING THE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH OF PREGNANT PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN STATE PRISONS IN
THREE KEY WAYS. IT REQUIRES THAT
INCARCERATED PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE
GIVEN AT LEAST 120OZ OF CLEAN
BOTTLED WATER, CODIFIES
REQUIREMENTS FOR NUTRITION
STANDARDS FOR INCARCERATED
PREGNANT PEOPLE, AND FINALLY
LIMITS THE USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE
WITH CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS FOR
SAFETY. THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT WILL
PROTECT ONE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND SETS
NEW STANDARDS FOR SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT, WHERE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NONE. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION. CALIFORNIA SOLIS
POLICY INSTITUTE. IT IS A HUMANE
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR I SEE NO MICS UP FOR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR GROVE IS
READY FOR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I WANT TO APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR COMING FORWARD
AND ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE WOMEN'S PRISONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE, UNDER ATTACK RIGHT NOW IN
MULTIPLE CASES POSTPARTUM ISSUES
LIKE THIS BILL ADDRESSES AND
PREGNANCY ISSUES LIKE THIS BILL
ADDRESSES. AND SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD AB
2537, AS MY COLLEAGUE THAT DID
THE PRESENTATION SAYS THAT IT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR PREGNANT
POSTPARTUM WOMEN. EXCEPT WHEN
THERE'S A SAFETY CONCERN,
OBVIOUSLY, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL WOMEN INMATES ARE TAKEN
CARE OF AND SERVED. AND I
APPRECIATE THIS, BILL. AND WHAT
IT'S TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. AND I
AGREE THAT IT WILL HELP KEEP
PRISONERS, WOMEN, FEMALE
PRISONERS SAFE, LIKE CHOWCHILLA,
I DO HAVE ONE PROBLEM THAT I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO LOOK AT AND
ADDRESS. IF WE'RE GOING TO
PROTECT WOMEN IN THESE PRISONS,
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
ALL WOMEN ARE PROTECTED. IN
2021, THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WAS REQUIRED DURING THEIR INTAKE
TO ASK THEIR GENDER IDENTITY FOR
INMATES, AND THEY ALLOWED THEM
TO CHANGE THEM FLUENTLY,
FLUIDLY. I GUESS CDCR IS ALSO
REQUIRES TO HOUSE INMATES WHO
ARE TRANSGENDER, REGARDLESS OF
GENDER. IF YOU COULD STICK TO
THE MERIT OF THE BILL, PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY, MA'AM. I AM
PROTECTING WOMEN AND POSTPARTUM
ISSUES, SO WE HAVE AN ISSUE IN
CHOWCHILLA, AND I'LL JUST BE
BRIEF, AND I'D LIKE TO READ A
LETTER IF I COULD, FROM A PRISON
INMATE IN CHOWCHILLA. SO THIS
BILL THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
PROTECTING POSTPARTUM WOMEN.
WOMEN ARE COMING PREGNANT IN
CHOWCHILLA, AND THEY'RE COMING
UP POSITIVE FOR AIDS. THIS BILL
DEALS WITH THE PREGNANCY. I HAVE
A LETTER HERE FROM SENATOR
GROVE. SO LONG AS THE LETTER IS
RELATED TO THE MERITS OF THE
BILL. INCARCERATED, PREGNANT.
IT'S FROM AN INCARCERATED WOMAN.
YES IT IS FROM AN INCARCERATED
WOMAN. SO IN BRIEF, I'M SURE
I'LL GET CUT OFF AGAIN FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, I HAD AN
INCARCERATED WOMAN FROM
CHOWCHILLA PRISON WHO'S DEALING
WITH THE PREGNANCY ISSUE OF A
RAPE OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
MALE ANATOMY IN THIS PRISON. IN
THIS BATHROOM AT CHOWCHILLA.
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP? THEY
HAND OUT CONDOMS. WHY DO YOU
NEED CONDOMS IN A WOMEN'S
PRISON? PAID FOR. I'M SORRY. IS
PERMISSION GRANTED? SENATOR
GROVE, STICK TO THE MERITS OF
THE BILL, PLEASE. WHY WOULD YOU
SEND OUT WHY? WE WOULD NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THE PREGNANCY
ISSUE IN PRISON, WHICH THIS BILL
ADDRESSES TO PROTECT PREGNANT
WOMEN. IF WE DIDN'T PASS OUT, IF
CONDOMS WERE NOT PASSED OUT IN A
STATE PRISON WHERE WE HAVE MALE
INDIVIDUALS. AND IN CHOWCHILLA.
SENATOR GROVE PREGNANCIES, THIS
IS THE LAST WARNING. YOUR MIC
WOULD BE CUT OFF. STICK TO THE
MERITS OF THE BILL. PREGNANCIES
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE WHERE WE
ALLOW POSTPARTUM TO THIS BILL
PROTECTS THOSE WOMEN AFTER THEY
DELIVER BABIES TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE TIME OFF TO RECOVER THIS.
SO I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL, AND I THINK
WE AS A WOMEN'S CAUCUS NEED TO
DO MORE TO PROTECT WOMEN IN
PRISON SITUATIONS THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE MATTER? SENATOR CUEVAS,
YOU MAY CLOSE. WELL, I WANT TO
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, FOR,
FOR KEEPING ORDER IN THIS
DISCUSSION. AND THIS BILL IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING WOMEN, IN OUR
PRISONS, WHO ARE GIVING BIRTH,
THAT WE ARE TREATING THEM WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY AND THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT, THEY HAVE THE
SIMPLEST THINGS CLEAN DRINKING
WATER, SAFE CONDITIONS, AND FREE
FROM SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, AS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE, AS THE BILL
SAYS, THAT WE ARE PROTECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
ENSURE WE HAVE A REAL STANDARDS
FOR WOMEN IN OUR PRISONS. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON A OVERALL BILL.
ARCHULETA Ã ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKESBURG.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DAWLEY AYE.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO OJOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL JONES. MCGUIRE
NILO. AYE. AYES 37. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM TWO,
66, 267 AND 271. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATOR WAHAB IS
PREPARED. ASSEMBLY BILL 2740 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON. AN ACT
RELATING TO INCARCERATED
PERSONS. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON, I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2740, WHICH ADDRESSES
CURRENT REGULATORY GAPS IN
PRENATAL AND POSTPARTUM CARE FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
STATE PRISON. THIS BILL AIMS TO
PROVIDE A HEALTHIER START TO A
CHILD'S LIFE BY CONNECTING THE
INCARCERATED PREGNANT WOMAN TO
SOCIAL WORKERS WITHIN SEVEN DAYS
OF THEIR ARRIVAL. AB 2740 ALSO
EXPANDS FAMILY VISITATION
ELIGIBILITY AND REQUIRES THE
EXPEDITED PROCESSING OF
VISITATION APPLICATIONS,
ENSURING THAT MOTHERS AND THEIR
NEWBORNS CAN HAVE THESE CRUCIAL
BONDS. THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED
WITH CDCR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
WITH THE BILL, AB 2740
RECOGNIZES BOTH THE FUNDAMENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND RIGHTS OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR NEWBORNS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR. UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO
OBJECTION. WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE MILO. AYE
EBCLC. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
I SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE FOR FULL HOUSE. AYES.
40 NOES. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 267. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2907 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURR. AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREARMS. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO
PRESENT AB 2907, WHICH WOULD
RESOLVE AN EXISTING DISPARITY
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW, WHICH
PLACES MORE STRINGENT FIREARMS
SURRENDER REQUIREMENTS UPON
THOSE SUBJECT TO A CIVIL
PROTECTIVE ORDER THAN THOSE
SUBJECT TO A CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDER. AB 2907 WOULD REQUIRE A
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT CONVICTED OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, STALKING, OR
ELDER ABUSE TO COMPLY WITH THE
SAME FIREARMS SURRENDER
PROCEDURES REQUIRED OF THOSE
SUBJECT TO AN EQUIVALENT CIVIL
PROTECTIVE ORDER. IT HAS LONG
BEEN THE POLICY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT THE SAFE AND
TIMELY RELINQUISHMENT OF
FIREARMS BY CRIMINALS AND
CONVICTED ABUSERS IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING VICTIMS FROM FURTHER
VIOLENCE, INJURY OR DEATH. AB
2907 HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH NO NO VOTES AND HAS
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I RODA-GIL AYE. ARCHULETA
I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO A TURBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG I. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. LET'S
CALL THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE A CHO
BOGUE. AYE AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SEN WIENER HAS
FILED ITEM 271. HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ JOYCE.
SUPPORT SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL
1282 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL. AN ACT RELATING TO
MENTAL HEALTH. SEN. WIENER I
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB 1282 TASKS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION, TO
DEVELOP A STATEWIDE STRATEGY TO
UNDERSTAND, COMMUNICATE AND
MITIGATE MENTAL HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH USE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA BY CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS ANY DISCUSSION ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTION. AYES 40 NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK IS ITEM TWO, 74,
TWO, 77 AND 278. SENATOR SKINNER.
AB 3240. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3240 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. AN ACT RELATING
TO STUDENT FINANCIAL AID. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB
3240 ENSURES THAT OUR STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANTS ARE NOT
PENALIZED IF THEY RECEIVE
PRIVATE SCHOLARSHIP SUPPORT. THE
BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SO FAR AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. PHENOMENAL.
NO DISCUSSION ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 40
NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
DURAZO HAS THE NEXT TWO BILLS
WHICH WOULD PUT HER AHEAD IN
FIRST PLACE. SORRY, SENATOR DODD
FILE ITEM 277. WE ARE READY NOW.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1413 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
SENATOR DURAZZO, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. LAST YEAR, AB
1633 CLOSED A LOOPHOLE IN THE
HRA WHERE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD INDEFINITELY DELAY SECRET
REVIEW AS A DE FACTO WAY TO DENY
HOUSING PROJECTS. STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE REQUESTED CLARIFICATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WAS ONLY
PULLED OFF CONSENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CHAPTER NINE
AMENDMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR NØ MIX UP ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTION. AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. FINAL ITEM
278. SENATOR DURAZZO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2525
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER AND ACT
RELATING TO STATE HIGHWAYS.
SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK YOU. AB
2525. WILL HELP THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER AGENCIES IN
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. IT
WILL DO THIS BY STREAMLINING THE
CITY'S ABILITY TO LEASE PROPERTY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION AT A REDUCED
RATE TO STORE RECREATIONAL
VEHICLES, WHILE THE FORMER
INHABITANTS RECEIVE SERVICES TO
RELIEVE HOMELESSNESS. SHORTLY
AFTER ASSUMING OFFICE, MAYOR
KAREN BASS LAUNCHED HER
SIGNATURE PROGRAM CALLED INSIDE
SAFE, TAKING IMMEDIATE CITYWIDE
ACTION TO VOLUNTARILY BRING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
INSIDE FROM TENTS AND OTHER
ENCAMPMENTS. IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM, THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IS IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
LOCATIONS TO STORE THE RVS THAT
ARE SURRENDERED OFF THE STREETS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY LOS
ANGELES MAYOR KAREN BASS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI, AL RODA-GIL. NO.
ARCHULETA HI, ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DAWLEY. NO. DODD AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN.
AYE. MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NO. NILO NO. JOBO. NO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. RA AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DURAZZO. AYE GLAZER.
AYE PADILLA. AYE AYES 31. NOES
NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT, SENATORS, WE ARE ABOUT TO
GO INTO OUR LUNCH FOR 45
MINUTES. WE'VE DONE 44 BILLS,
BUT EIGHT OF THEM ARE ON CALL.
PLEASE STAY IN THE BUILDING NOW.
RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. WE WILL CAUCUS
NOW AS 1230 DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN
THE MADI LOUNGE. 1230. THANK
YOU, SENATOR JONES. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, REPUBLICANS
WILL CAUCUS IN ROOM 215 AFTER WE
GRAB OUR LUNCH FOR A BRIEF
CONVERSATION ABOUT SOMETHING.
SENATORS, 45 MINUTES. SEE YOU IN
45 MINUTES.
WE ARE BACK IN SESSION. WE'RE
STARTING WITH ITEM 156. SENATOR
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2099 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 2099
PROTECTS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE PATIENTS AND THEIR
PROVIDERS BY UPDATING THE
PENALTIES FOR HARASSMENT AND
VIOLATION OF A PATIENT'S
PRIVACY. THE BILL IS CRITICAL AS
VIOLENCE IS ON THE RISE AT
CLINICS AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? OUR FINAL ITEM 156.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL NØ ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE NO. HURTADO JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO.
COBO PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. OH, NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. BECKER AYE. DAWLEY
HURTADO. LIMON MCGUIRE. MILO. NO
BOGUE. NO RUBIO. YEAH STERN.
WILK SENATOR. SKINNER MOVES A
CALL. THE NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE
FILE ITEM 282, 285 AND 289.
SENATOR CABALLERO IS NEXT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 2926 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE. SENATOR CABALLERO
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT
GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
PRESENT AB 2926 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. THE BILL
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA PROTECT OUR
LIMITED AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK
AND PREVENT LOW INCOME TENANTS
FROM BEING DISPLACED. THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION NOTICE
LAW REQUIRES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OWNERS WITH EXPIRING
RESTRICTIONS TO ALLOW BUYERS
INTERESTED IN PRESERVING THE
AFFORDABILITY. A YEAR'S NOTICE
TO MAKE A BONA FIDE PURCHASE,
AND GIVES THEM THE RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL TO MATCH ANY OTHER
OFFERS. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
ALSO MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE LAW TO INCLUDE RECENTLY
ENACTED STREAMLINING LEGISLATION
TO PREVENT TENANTS FROM BEING
DISPLACED OR PRICED OUT WITHOUT
NOTICE. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ELIGIBLE, BUT WE
WERE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL. IF
I SEE NO MIX UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GLASER. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. MILO AYE.
OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
SENATOR CABALLERO MOVES THE
CALL. SENATOR MIN IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. PHÐ.
ITEM 285. ASSEMBLY BILL 1825 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. AN
ACT RELATING TO LIBRARIES.
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATORS, I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AB 1825 THE
CALIFORNIA FREEDOM TO READ ACT.
THIS BILL WAS DRAFTED IN
COLLABORATION WITH LIBRARIANS
AND FIRST AMENDMENT LAWYERS. WE
KNOW THAT THE FREEDOM TO READ IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY,
BUT IT'S BEEN UNDER ATTACK IN
RECENT YEARS, ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN LIBRARY ASSOCIATION'S
OFFICE FOR INTELLECTUAL FREEDOM,
CHALLENGES OF UNIQUE TITLES IN
THE UNITED STATES INCREASED 65%
FROM 2022 TO 2023, REACHING THE
HIGHEST EVER LEVEL RECORDED BY
THE ALA. CENSORSHIP AND BOOK
BANS ARE, OF COURSE, NOT NEW IN
AMERICA TODAY. AT AN EARLIER,
UGLIER TIME IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS
LIKE SHAKESPEARE'S WORKS, THE
DIARY OF ANNE FRANK AND EVEN
ROBIN HOOD WERE BANNED AS
OBSCENE OR, AND INVARIABLY THESE
BANS TURN POLITICAL. TODAY, THIS
PRIMARILY TARGETS THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES AND VOICES OF
LGBTQIA AND BLACK INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF COLOR, AS THESE MADE
UP 40%, 47% OF BOOKS TARGETED IN
CENSORSHIP ATTEMPTS IN
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
ALA REPORTED THAT IN 2023 WE SAW
52 CHALLENGES TO 98 TITLES IN
PUBLIC LIBRARIES AND SCHOOL
LIBRARIES. AND THIS, OF COURSE,
WE'VE SEEN SEVERAL
MUNICIPALITIES, INCLUDING MY
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH, PASS
BOOK BANS OR ORDINANCES TO
CENSOR BOOKS. AB 1825 WOULD
PROHIBIT PUBLIC LIBRARIES FROM
BANNING BOOKS BASED ON PARTIZAN
OR POLITICAL REASONS. VIEWPOINT
DISCRIMINATION, GENDER SEXUAL
IDENTITY, RELIGION, DISABILITY,
OR ON THE BASIS THAT THE BOOKS
CONTAIN INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES. ADDITIONALLY, THE
BILL REQUIRES PUBLIC LIBRARY
JURISDICTIONS THAT RECEIVE STATE
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH A
COLLECTION DEVELOPMENT POLICY
FOR THE SELECTION OF LIBRARY
MATERIALS AND THE USE OF LIBRARY
MATERIALS AND FACILITIES. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF ACCESS TO
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE BOOKS AND
LIBRARY MATERIALS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR MIN, I AM SEEING NO MIX
UP ON THIS ITEM. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI,
AL. RODA-GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DEL. NÓ DODD. AYE. HUESO. AYE
EGGMAN. GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN MILO. NO.
AYE. TROBERG. PADILLA POR.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO.
GILL EGGMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE NGUYEN.
OKOBO STERN. SENATOR MIN MOVES
TO CALL, STARTING OFF A LITTLE
ROUGH AFTER LUNCH. SENATOR
RUBIO, YOU'RE UP NEXT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2543 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACT RELATING TO
SMALL BUSINESS. SENATOR RUBIO,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2543 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA, WHICH
WILL PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AND
SERVICES TO ELIGIBLE BUSINESS
OWNERS. AB 2543 IS SPONSORED BY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE AND IS
SUPPORTED BY MANY RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU. AND I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I SEE NO MICS UP FOR
DISCUSSION. WE'RE GOING TO BE
PLACING THIS ON CALL. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONCE ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY. NO DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. WAYNE NO. NILO. NO
TRUMBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A CALL.
THE NEXT THREE ON DECK FIVE.
ITEM TWO 9293 AND 294. SENATOR
WIENER, YOU ARE UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 290.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3122 BY CARILLO.
AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE
SUPPORT. SUPPORT. SENATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 3122 MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
CORRECTIONS TO SB 35. SB 42
THREE TO STREAMLINE HOUSING
APPROVALS, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
AYE. DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. MILO. AYE. AYE JOBO.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. SATO.
AYE SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. WILK.
RIVAS AYE. STERN. HAMBURG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SEN. WIENER. MOVES THE
CALL. SENATOR RUBIO, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 293. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1906
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON. AN
ACT RELATING TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. SENATOR RUBIO,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1906 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON, WHICH SEEKS TO
CONDUCT A STUDY PERTAINING TO
ELDERLY TERMINOLOGY. I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR, UP FOR
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ONCE. ALAN Ã
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ DALLEY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER A SMALL.
CUEVAS EYES TURN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. SENATOR RUBIO MOVES
THE CALL. SENATOR ASHBY IS ON
DECK. SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE
ITEM 294. ASSEMBLY BILL 3253 BY
MEMBER BERMAN AND AQUILINA.
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3253 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. THIS BILL IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS, LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FANTASTIC. SENATOR, I'M
SEEING NO MIKES UP FOR
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. I'LL GO.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I AM IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE MILO. AYE
DROBO. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AL-WAHHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR ASHBY
MOVES A CALL. THE NEXT THREE
FILES ON DECK ARE FILED. ITEM
2972 98 AND 299. SENATOR CORTESE
IS PREPARED FOR ITEM 297.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2725 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCO RUBIO. AN ACT RELATING TO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. SENATOR
CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, SENATORS, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB 2725
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO. THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
SPECIFIED THERAPISTS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION SETTINGS, WHICH IS NOT
THE CASE RIGHT NOW, AUTHORIZING
OCCUPATIONAL AND PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS TO OBTAIN AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
CREDENTIAL WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
INTO ADMINISTRATIVE ROLES AND
SHARE THEIR UNIQUE EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM
297? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OAN Ã. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD LORENZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO.
HIGH AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE
LIMÓN. AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. OCHOA AYE.
PERDUE. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. A SMALL CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. SENATOR. CORTEZ MOVES TO
CALL. WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE SKIPPING ITEM 288. THE NEXT
TWO ARE GOING TO BE 299 AND 301.
SENATOR DURAZZO, YOU ARE MAKING
A COMEBACK. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 3265 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN. AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SENATOR DURAZZO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL,
AB 3265, WILL BE A CATALYST FOR
SUSTAINED JOB GROWTH BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS FOR
RENOVATING SOUNDSTAGES AND
UPDATING PRODUCTION FACILITIES
TO INCORPORATE THE LATEST
GRAPHICS AND AUDIO TECHNOLOGY.
THIS BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
FANTASTIC SENATOR. I SEE NO
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I RODA-GIL
I ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE CABRERA I CORTEZ.
AYE. DAWLEY I DODD. TERRAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN I GLASER. I GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE I URDAHL I JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN I NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE MILO. AYE TRUMBO.
PADILLA PORTANTINO I ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES THE CAR.
COLLEAGUES, WE HAVE ANOTHER
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US TODAY.
FORMER ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN
LEADER CONNIE CONWAY IS IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS. THANK YOU.
AND IN WITH THEME WITH TODAY. I
FOR THE RECORD, SHE ATTACKED ME
IN THE HALLWAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR LEHMAN HAS FILED
ITEM 301. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2508 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTHY. AN ACT RELATING
TO STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
SENATOR LEHMAN, THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2508 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AB 2508
EXPANDS ACCESS TO CAL KIDS FOR.
AB 2508 EXPANDS ACCESS TO CAL
KIDS FOR FOSTER YOUTH. AB 2508
WILL EXPAND ELIGIBILITY IN FIRST
THROUGH 12TH GRADE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEHMAN. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM 301. ALAN A RODA-GIL A
ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER. BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD. DURAZO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES, I LAIRD. I LEHMAN. I
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN. NEWMAN
I WAYNE, I MILO, I JOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG. WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK, I SENATOR LYMAN MOVES
THE CALL THE NEXT THREE ON DECK
FILE ITEM 306 309 AND 313.
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS FILED ITEM
306. SENATOR BRADFORD IS ON DECK.
WE ARE WAITING FOR SENATOR
BRADFORD TO BE READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1877
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON. AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. 1877 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN JACKSON WILL REQUIRE
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICER TO
PETITION A COURT TO SEAL CERTAIN
RECORDS OF ANY PERSON PREVIOUSLY
DETERMINED TO BE A WARD OF THE
COURT WHO HAS REACHED THE AGE OF
18 AND WHO IS NO LONGER UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THE JUVENILE
COURT. 1877 GIVES OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THEIR BEST SHOT AT A
BETTER LIFE TO PURSUE AN
EDUCATION, START A BUSINESS OR
BUY A HOME. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO GÒM NØ
ARCHULETA I. ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ. HI,
DARLING NØ DODD I DURAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NØ HURTADO I JONES NÓ.
LAIRD I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NÓ NILO NÓ. JOBO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I. ROTH I RUBIO.
SEYARTO NØ. NÓ. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG. WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK. NÓ SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES A CALL. SENATOR
WAHAB HAS FILED ITEM 309.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2801 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
TENANCY. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AB 20 801
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, WHICH STRENGTHENS
RENTER PROTECTIONS BY PREVENTING
UNFAIR SECURITY DEPOSIT
DEDUCTIONS. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
LANDLORDS CAN ONLY CLAIM FUNDS
FROM A SECURITY DEPOSIT IF THEY
ARE REASONABLY NECESSARY FOR THE
REPAIR OF DAMAGES TO THE
PREMISES. HOWEVER, THEY ARE
STILL ABLE TO WITHHOLD ALL OR
PARTS OF THE DEPOSIT WITH A
VALID REASON OR EVIDENCE. AB 20
801 LIMITS LANDLORDS FROM
DEDUCTING SECURITY DEPOSIT COSTS
UNLESS NECESSARY, TO RESTORE THE
PROPERTY TO ITS ORIGINAL
CONDITION, EXCLUDING NORMAL WEAR
AND TEAR, AND REQUIRES DETAILED
DOCUMENTATION AND PHOTOS FOR ANY
DEDUCTIONS. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RENTERS EXTRA PROTECTIONS
REGARDING SECURITY DEPOSITS,
WHILE STILL PRESERVING THE
LANDLORD'S RIGHT TO DEDUCT.
DEDUCT FROM SECURITY DEPOSIT ANY
REPAIRS OF DAMAGES CAUSED BY THE
TENANT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NÓ MIX UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL. NO
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
HI, DARLING. NO NO. DODD. AYE.
RAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR I
AM IN NO. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
SENATOR WAHAB MOVES A CALL.
YEAH. SENATOR LIMON HAS FILED
ITEM 313. SHE'S READY TO GO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 1780 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. AN ACT
RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATE. LEMON, YOU'RE
CURRENTLY IN FIRST PLACE. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I WILL TAKE
THAT RECOGNITION. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1780 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. SB 1780
WILL PROHIBIT CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING FROM
PARTICIPATING IN LEGACY AND
DONOR ADMISSIONS BY STOPPING
LEGACY ADMISSIONS AS AB 1780
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ADMITTED TO
THEIR DREAM SCHOOL, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I SEE NO DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL, NO. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE DAWLEY. DODD
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I AM IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. MILO. NO.
TRUMBO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
SENATOR LEMON MOVES A CALL. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM
316, 321 AND 324. SENATOR ROTH
HAS FILED ITEM 316. ENJOY.
SUPPORT SUPPORT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1976
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY. AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH. SENATOR ROTH, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THE BILL
ENSURES WIDESPREAD ACCESS TO
NALOXONE IN CALIFORNIA BY
REQUIRING IT TO BE IN ALL
LOCATIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
HAVE A WORKPLACE FIRST AID KIT.
AS PHªN, I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO GÒM.
AYE. ARCHULETA Ã ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY. AYE DODD.
AYE DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL FAVORS. AYE STERN. AYE
UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK AYE. SENATOR ROTH MOVES THE
CALL. SENATOR GROVE IS UP FOR
FIVE FROM 321. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3193 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON, I PRESENT AB 3193 AB
3193 WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION TO
AWARD CONTRACTS FOR ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY WITHOUT COMPETITION
OR ADVERTISING. IF THE VALUE OF
THE PURCHASE IS LESS THAN
$10,000. ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGIES
CAN RANGE FROM SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS A WHEELCHAIR TO MORE
COMPLEX TECHNOLOGY. AS SPEECH
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE THAT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF THOSE WITH DISABILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS A LACK
OF VENDORS FOR SEVERAL KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES IN THIS STATE, AND
THE STATE HAS STRUGGLED,
STRUGGLED FOR DECADES TO FIND
COMPETITIVE PROCESS TO TAKE
PLACE. WITH SO FEW VENDORS, AB
3193 ENSURES THAT ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY, DEVICES AND SERVICES
PROCURED ARE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SO FAR. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB 3193.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. THANK
YOU. SENATOR GROVE, NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN Ã
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DELHI AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. OTERO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NHIÀU. AYE. OJOBO.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL
FAVORS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR GROVE MOVES THE CALL.
SENATOR DODD IS UP FROM 324.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2948 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. AN ACT RELATING TO
FIRE PROTECTION. SENATOR DODD,
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CONNOLLY TO
PRESENT AB 2968. THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
FULLY PREPARED TO RESPOND
SWIFTLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
PROTECT STUDENT AND STAFF SAFETY
IN THE EVENT OF A WILDFIRE
EMERGENCY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. COLLEAGUES,
ANY DISCUSSION? NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY AYE. DODD AYE.
DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE OR
DATO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NIILO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
MACGREGOR'S AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK AYE. Ã. AYE. SENATOR DODD
MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP IS FIRE
ITEM 325. 328 AND 329. SENATOR
DODD MOVING INTO ONCE AGAIN,
FIRST PLACE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2991 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, VALENCIA. AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR DODD. MADAM
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2991. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
FUNDS TRANSFER FOR ALL
TRANSACTIONS BETWEEN ALCOHOL
RETAILERS AND DISTRIBUTORS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. NÓ MIKE.
SUP, SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. DATO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
MILO. AYE TROBO. AYE PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. MOORLACH. RIVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. SENATOR
DODD MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
GLASER IS UP. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3218 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOOD. AN ACT
RELATING TO TOBACCO AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR.
SENATOR GLASER, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD, I'M
PRESENTING THIS BILL MANY OF YOU
MAY RECALL THAT SENATE BILL 793
BANNED FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY STILL REMAIN READILY
AVAILABLE IN OUR STATE. A 2023
STUDY BY THE CDC INDICATED THAT
AMONG MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO USE TOBACCO, NEARLY
90% USE FLAVORED PRODUCTS. THIS
BILL CREATES A PATHWAY TO ENSURE
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE NO
LONGER AVAILABLE ON THE SHELVES
OF RETAILERS AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY BY CREATING AN
AFFIRMATIVE LISTING OF FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS APPROACH WILL
HELP RETAILERS DETERMINE AT A
GLANCE WHETHER A PRODUCT
DELIVERED TO THEIR STORES IS
LEGAL OR NOT. ADDITIONALLY, THE
BILL AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO PENALIZE DISTRIBUTORS
THAT SELL ILLEGAL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND MANUFACTURERS THAT
FALSELY CERTIFY THEIR PRODUCTS
AS UNFLAVORED. FINALLY, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
SEIZE ILLEGAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
FROM DISTRIBUTORS. MEMBERS.
THESE COMPREHENSIVE ENFORCEMENT
STEPS WILL HELP IMPLEMENT THE
FLAVORED TOBACCO BAN THE WAY IT
WAS INTENDED. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SEN. GLASER. I
SEE NO DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY. WE MAY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKESBURG.
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. CORTEZ
AYE. DALY. NO. DODD. AYE
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN
HI. MIN NO. NGUYEN MILO. NO.
JOBO NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
NO SKINNER. A SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. GROVE NO.
MCGUIRE NGUYEN. STERN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE
MORE TIME. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
MCGUIRE NGUYEN STERN. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
MCGUIRE. NGUYEN STERN. STERN.
AYE. AYES 29. NOES SEVEN. WERE
NOT PLACING THIS ITEM ON CALL.
FANTASTIC. MEASURE PASSES SEN.
ROTH IS READY FOR ITEM 329.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3161 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
REQUIRES HOSPITAL SAFETY PLANS
TO INCLUDE A PROCESS FOR
ADDRESSING RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION AND ITS IMPACTS
ON PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY. AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WE ARE ALL
HERE. FANTASTIC. ANY OBJECTION?
AYES 39. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE ARE JUMPING BACK TO
FILE ITEM 298. SENATOR BECKER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1824 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA. AN ACT RELATING TO
PRIVACY. SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES THIS BILL AMENDS
THE CALIFORNIA PRIVACY ACT SO
THAT UNDER MERGERS AND
ACQUISITIONS, THE MERGING
COMPANY CUSTOMERS ARE NOTIFIED
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO OPT OUT
OF DATA. IT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION?
WE'RE BACK ON TRACK. THIS ITEM
IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES
39. NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT THREE COLLEAGUES, ARE YOU
READY FOR ITEM 331? 333 AND 335.
SENATOR CORTESE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 871
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY. AN ACT
RELATING TO SAFETY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT. SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
SENATORS, RISE TO PRESENT AB
871. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HANEY. THE BILL AIMS TO INCREASE
THE REQUIRED WORK EXPERIENCE IN
THE CONVEYANCE INDUSTRY THAT AN
APPLICANT FOR CERTIFICATION MUST
HAVE FROM 3 TO 4 YEARS. AMONGST
OTHER THINGS, AMENDMENTS NARROW
THE BILL'S SCOPE BY REMOVING THE
SECTION ON CONVEYANCES IN
PRIVATE RESIDENCES. ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR NÓ
MIKE. SUP, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN Ã GÒM NØ
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. A DALLY. NO.
DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER NO. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NO. MILO NO. COBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH RUBIO. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL FAVORS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO DODD. JONES MCGUIRE.
MIN. NEWMAN ROTH. RUBIO. AYE.
AYES 24. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR PADILLA IS ON
DECK. HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 333.
ASSEMBLY BILL 799 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US AND AQUILINA.
HOMELESSNESS. SENATOR PADILLA.
THIS IS A JOINT SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
799 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THREE OF US, WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE'S EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
ENHANCED COORDINATION,
ACCOUNTABILITY, TRANSPARENCY AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, HAS
HAD ZERO NO VOTES, WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I SEE NO
MICS UP. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES AYES 39. NO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR DURAZO, FOR ITEM 335.
SHE'S READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2364 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US. AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR DURAZZO. MADAM PRESIDENT.
AB 32364 WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO COMMISSION A STUDY
FROM ENTITIES WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
IMPROVE WORKER SAFETY AND
SAFEGUARD EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS IN
THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND ALSO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL OF THE
BILL TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. I'LL GO. NO ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY DODD. DALLEY.
NÓ DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. NO. COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CLOVIS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. NO NGUYEN. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WICKS. DODD
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. AYE JONES.
LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE. EYES 27.
NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE NEXT THREE ON DECK. FILE
ITEM 336, 338 AND 339. SENATOR
LAIRD IS EAGERLY AWAITING.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2902 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD. AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID
WASTE. SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. SB 1383 AND
2016 BY THEN SENATOR RICARDO
LARA ESTABLISHED A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK ON REDIRECTING ORGANIC
WASTE SENT TO LANDFILLS. THIS
BILL STRIKES A BALANCE AND GIVES
SOME FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
GOALS TO RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NØ MIX UP
OAN. AYE AYE. RODA-GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD DURAZO. I.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. TROUBLE I.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILL.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES. MCGUIRE MIN. AYE
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. MEASURE.
PASSES. SEN. UMBERG. ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR ITEM 338.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2655 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
OF TECHNOLOGY IS THAT TODAY YOU
CAN CREATE IMAGES THAT MAY NOT
BEAR ANY RESEMBLANCE TO REALITY.
SOME ARE CALLED DEEPFAKES.
DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY CAN CREATE
FALSE AUDIO, FALSE VISUAL MEDIA
THAT IS WIDELY ACCESSIBLE AND
CAN BE USED TO PROVIDE
MISINFORMATION. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS THAT IT PROVIDES A BASIS
TO COMPLAIN. BASICALLY, FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE PLATFORM
SAYING THAT THERE IS AI
GENERATED DEEPFAKES THAT
IMPERSONATE EITHER POLITICIANS,
CELEBRITIES, OR OTHERS, AND THAT
THAT AT THAT POINT IN TIME, THE
PLATFORM MUST TAKE IT DOWN IF
IT'S HARMFUL. BUT LESS DECEPTIVE
CONTENT. THE BILL REQUIRES
PLATFORMS TO LABEL IT AS
ELECTION DISINFORMATION. I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
UMBERG. COLLEAGUES, ANY
DISCUSSION? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. I'LL
RATHER GO. NØ. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO. DATO
JONES. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. I AM IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. JOBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO. NØ
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL FAVORS.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER
JONES. MCGUIRE. OCHOA. BOGH
RUBIO. SMALL. CUEVAS. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. BECKER AYE. JONES.
MCGUIRE. OKOBO. RUBIO. SMALL.
CUEVAS.
SENATOR. UMBERG MOVES A CALL.
SENATOR PADILLA IS PREPARED FOR
ITEM 339. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
26. ASSEMBLY BILL 1359 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR PADILLA.
THIS INJURY SUPPORT, SUPPORT,
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN TO PRESENT
AB 1359 TO JUMPSTART GEOTHERMAL
ENERGY PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
AN OLD MISGUIDED PROVISION OF
LAW DESIGNATES CAL JIM AS ALWAYS,
THE LEAD AGENCY FOR EXPLORATORY
GEOTHERMAL WELLS. RATHER THAN
THE TYPICAL LOCAL AGENCY LEAD.
IT HAS ACHIEVED THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT FROM STREAMLINING. THIS
BILL ALLOWS APPLICANTS TO OPT IN
TO THE TYPICAL LOCAL LEAD AGENCY,
FOR SEQUA DOES NOT WEAKEN SEQUA
IN ANY WAY. THE BILL HAS BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I THINK WE HAVE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS ON
SUPPORT. SUPPORT SPEECHES, ANY
MIX UP ON DISCUSSION? THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 39.
NO ZERO. MEASURE PASSES ON THE
URGENCY. EIS 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR UP NEXT,
THE THREE ARE FOR ITEM THREE,
4341 AND 344. SENATOR LAIRD IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM. 340 ASSEMBLY BILL
2705 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ORTEGA.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC WORKS.
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS TIME TO RECOVER
UNPAID WAGES FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO WAGE THEFT ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. THERE'S AN
INCONSISTENCY IN TWO STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS. THAT MEANS THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER COULD BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF AN ASSESSMENT AND
RUN OUT OF TIME TO RECOVER THE
WAGES OWED TO WORKERS FROM THE
BONDING COMPANY. THIS SIMPLY
ALIGNS THE TWO STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS. SO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS UP TO 18 MONTHS
TO MAKE BOTH THE ASSESSMENT AND
SUE THE BONDING COMPANY TO
RECOVER THE WORKER'S WAGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I SEE NO MICROPHONES UP FOR THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON HÌNH ALVARADO. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DELHI
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAESER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN WHEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
DROBO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE. RIVAS
EYES TURN. AYE. HAMBURG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
NGUYEN. IDA. NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER. AYE
GROVE. MCGUIRE NEWMAN. OJOBO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE. MCGUIRE
NEWMAN. AYE BOCOBO. AYES 36.
NOES ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR JONES IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 341.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3016 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. AN ACCOLADE TO
HOUSING.
SENATOR JONES, YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I AM PRESENTING FILE
ITEM 341, WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
3116 BY OUR ESTEEMED ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE, EDUARDO GARCIA. IT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO
STUDENT HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION? ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. DO WE
HAVE AN OBJECTION? AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATORS, WE HAVE A ROUND. TWO
OF SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE BACK.
WE HAVE THE SECOND GROUP OF OUR
SPECIAL. SPECIAL SERVICES IN THE
BACK. IF WE CAN STAND UP AND
GIVE THIS GROUP A RECOGNITION
AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR HARD
WORK.
UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM 344.
SENATOR UMBERG. YOU'VE DONE IT.
IT IS THE ONLY DECENT THING.
OOPS COLLEAGUES, WE ARE ON FILE
ITEM 344 AB 2863. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2863
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SCHIAVO. AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS.
SENATOR. UMBERG. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE. TO PRESENT AB 2863 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO.
AUTOMATIC SUBSCRIPTION RENEWALS
CAN OFFER CONVENIENCE IN TOO
MANY INSTANCES, CONSUMERS ARE
BILLED FOR SERVICES THEY NO
LONGER WANT. IN FACT, IN 2022,
RESEARCH FOUND THAT ON AVERAGE,
42% OF CONSUMERS FORGOT THEY
WERE STILL PAYING FOR A
SUBSCRIPTION THAT THEY NO LONGER
USED. ALL OF US HAVE PERSONAL
STORIES. I'M SURE MANY OF US ARE
STILL SUBSCRIBING TO BOYS LIFE,
SUCH AS I AM, WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ACCOMPLISH MAKES IT EASY FOR
CONSUMER TO UNSUBSCRIBE OR TO
CANCEL A SUBSCRIPTION REQUIRES
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT FOR AN
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL, AND IT
PROVIDES. NOTICE THE AMOUNT OF
RAIN OR RANGE OF COST TO THE
CONSUMER, AND IT PROHIBITS
BUSINESSES FROM OBSTRUCTING OR
DELAYING A REQUEST TO CANCEL
WHILE STILL ALLOWING A BUSINESS
TO ATTEMPT TO KEEP THE CUSTOMER.
I URGE, AND I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR UMBERG. COLLEAGUES ANY
DISCUSSION ON ITEM. 344 SENATOR
DOLLY, YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM SPEAKER. MEMBERS, I
JUST WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THIS HAS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TO ME, TRYING TO GET
RID OF, ANNUAL SUBSCRIPTIONS. SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
UMBERG, YOU MAY CLOSE. I URGE,
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I VOTED GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
AYE. DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE POTATO. AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE. TROBERG.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
QUAVERS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE MCGUIRE.
MIN SEYARTO. WIENER. AYE. AYE.
TO NO. AYES 35. NOES ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. THE THREE NEXT
ARE GOING TO BE FILED. ITEM 346,
348 AND 349. SENATOR CUEVAS HAS
FILED ITEM 346. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2602
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATORS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIX 2602 WHICH WOULD REQUIRE A
PERFORMERS INFORMED CONSENT AND
PROPER REPRESENTATION WHEN
EXECUTING A CONTRACT FOR ANY
TRANSFER OF RIGHTS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL'S LIKENESS OR VOICE.
AMIDST THE RISE OF THE DIGITAL
AGE, PERFORMERS ACROSS THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY BEEN SIGNING AWAY
THEIR RIGHTS TO THEIR DIGITAL
SELVES THROUGH CLAUSES THAT CAN
LOOK LIKE STANDARD COPYRIGHT
LANGUAGE. AB 2602 STRIKES THE
BALANCE BETWEEN INDUSTRY
PROGRESS AND PROTECTING A
PERFORMER'S RIGHTS TO THEIR
DIGITAL SELF AND LIVELIHOOD.
THIS BILL DOES NOT OUTRIGHT
PROHIBIT THE USE OF DIGITAL
REPLICAS, BUT RATHER ENSURES
THAT IF PERFORMERS AGREE TO
LICENSE OUT THEIR DIGITAL SELF
THAT THEY ARE FULLY AWARE OF THE
EXTENT OF AND THE INTENTIONS FOR
THAT USE, AND THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
DISCUSSION? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DODD TERRAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NILO AYE. OKOBO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
HAMBURG AYE. WAHAB WIENER. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD AYE. GROVE MCGUIRE.
MEN AYE. NGUYEN OKOBO. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. AYES 36.
NOES ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR LEHMAN, YOU ARE UP. YOU
ARE TIED FOR FIRST PLACE. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S DO THIS. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 348.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2680 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. AN ACT
RELATING TO ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
SENATOR LEHMAN. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AB 2680 UPDATES THE NAME
OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
ASSOCIATED TERMINOLOGY TO REMOVE
STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE WHILE
EXPANDING THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM.
348 THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM
THREE, 51, 352, AND 353. SENATOR
WILK, YOU HAVE FILE ITEM 351.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2499 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SCHIAVO. AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR WILK. I'M
SORRY. I HAVE THE WRONG SCRIPT.
JUST DO IT WITHOUT NOTES. I
DIDN'T NO ONE CAME TO TELL ME
THAT THAT WAS UP. I'M HAPPY TO
DO THIS ONE. GOT IT. THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT. AB 2499 ENSURES
THAT EMPLOYEES WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE OR HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER WHO IS A VICTIM, CANNOT
BE FIRED OR FACE DISCRIMINATION
FOR TAKING TIME OFF TO SEEK
SUPPORT FOR THEMSELVES OR THEIR
LOVED ONES. THIS BILL APPLIES TO
EMPLOYERS WITH 25 OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. ALIGNING WITH CURRENT
LAW AND LIMITS FAMILY LEAVE TO
TWO WEEKS TO BALANCE THE NEEDS
OF BUSINESSES. IN RESPONSE TO
FEEDBACK, WE HAVE AMENDED THE
BILL TO ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM
SMALL BUSINESSES AND STREAMLINE
THE LEAVE REQUEST PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHEN DISCUSSING
CRIME VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS ARE
OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION. THEY NEED OUR
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
TIME TO HEAL WITH A PEACE OF
MIND THAT THEY WON'T LOSE THEIR
JOBS. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. I SEE NO
MIKES UP. WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL NOW. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. OTERO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN. NO.
NILO OCHOA. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE GILL. I DON'T
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER AYE. LAZO AYE.
MCGUIRE. NEWMAN. AYE. NILO. AYES
31. NO. SEVEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR LIMON KNOCKING
IT OUT OF THE PARK. YOU ARE UP
WITH FIVE. ITEM 352. YOU'VE
REGAINED THE FIRST PLACE SLOT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1005 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. AN ACT RELATING
TO IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
SENATOR LIMON. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TEN ZERO FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. AB TEN
ZERO FIVE AIMS TO PROVIDE
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE FOR
VULNERABLE HOSPITAL PATIENTS
INTERESTED IN IHSS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THERE'S NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE OR OBJECTION. AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES, WE ARE GOING TO GO
BACK INTO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PURSUANT TO JOINT RULE 33.1,
JOINT RULE 61 WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE,
ONE, ONE, THREE, 24, 60 AND 2629
TO BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THE. THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
I AM NOW RECOGNIZING OUR
MAJORITY LEADER, SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THERE'S A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
61 AND 62 FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING SENATE POLICY AND
FISCAL COMMITTEES TO MEET AND
HEAR ACR 210 AFTER THE
DEADLINES. THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE? WE
OBJECT TO THESE AMENDMENTS AND
WOULD LIKE A NO VOTE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS REQUESTING AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR IS REQUESTING A NO
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
RESOLVED THAT JOINT RULE 61 AND
62 BE DISPENSED WITH. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OAN Ã
ALVARADO. NO. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY. NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
I. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO. DATO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OKOBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL CUEVAS EYES.
TURN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
AYE. MCGUIRE AYES 30. NOES NINE.
THE MOTION PASSES. THE JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. SEN.
GONZALEZ, YOU ARE ONCE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
ASSEMBLY BILLS EIGHT, 63, 22,
50, 22, 63 AND 2851 TO BE
AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE ALSO BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU, MAJORITY LEADER.
SENATOR SERRATO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. AGAIN, WE WOULD LIKE
TO ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS OF
THE SUSPENSION OF THE RULES, AND
WE CAN APPLY THE PREVIOUS ROLL
CALL VOTE TO THIS ONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE 61
BE DISPENSED WITH UTILIZING THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 39. NO
ZERO. JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
AYES 39. AYES 30. NOES NINE.
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MOVING BACK ON OUR FILE, WE HAVE
FILE NUMBER. WE'RE STILL UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
LARRY, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION OF FILE
ITEM 336. ASSEMBLY BILL 2902.
THE DESK HAS NOTED WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SENATOR. LAIRD. COLLEAGUE.
SENATOR LAIRD IS ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON AB 2902. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION? I AM SEEING
NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO.
RECONSIDERATION Ó.
RECONSIDERATION. RECONSIDERATION
IS GRANTED.
THIS ITEM WILL NOT BE PRESENTED.
WE ARE JUST TAKING A ROLL CALL
ON. AB 2902, FILE NUMBER 336.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER BLAKESBURG. NO. BRADFORD
HI. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAESER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. OR
DATO? AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
I. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO I. SATO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. HAMBURG BY
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER MCGUIRE.
PADILLA. AYE AYES 37 NOES. ONE
MEASURE PASSES. ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS? UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTION, I AM SEEING NONE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE FOR ITEM
353, 357 AND 360. SENATOR
DURAZZO IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ITEM 353. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2192 BY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. SENATOR
DURAZZO, THIS IS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AB 2192
SEEKS TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA UNIFORM CONSTRUCTION
COST ACCOUNTING COMMISSIONS
APPROVED INCREASES IN BIDDING
LIMIT THRESHOLDS FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO ACCOUNT
FOR RISING INFLATION AND
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT COSTS, AND
WILL INCLUDE TECHNICAL CHANGES.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR
DURAZZO. I SEE NO MIX UP ON THIS
ITEM. IT'S ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
BECKER. THIS IS YOUR SHOW,
SENATOR BECKER. ITEM 357 AB
2109. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2109 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY. SENATOR
BECKER. AYE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
TREAT INDUSTRIAL PROCESS HEAT
RECOVERY AS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TECHNOLOGY AND THEREFORE WOULD
REMOVE THE PUNITIVE DEPARTING
LOAD CHARGE COMPANIES WOULD HAVE
TO PAY IF THEY REDUCE THEIR
DEMAND. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANY MIX UP? SECRETARY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN A MCGILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBURG. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN MILO. AYE. OKOBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH HI. RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG A WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TALLEY AYE. MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. MCGUIRE OKOBOJI.
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR HARB, YOU HAVE
FIREARM IN 360. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3077
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HART. I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 3077, WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS WITH BORDERLINE
PERSONALITY DISORDER TO ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS, GIVING JUDGES THE
DISCRETION TO CONSIDER THE
DISORDER AND SENTENCING
DECISIONS AND POTENTIALLY
REDUCING THESE SENTENCES WHEN
ELIGIBLE JUDGES ALSO HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO REDUCE THE
PENALTIES FOR A DEFENDANT WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS IF DOING SO IS IN
THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, JUDGES MAY CONSIDER A
DEFENDANT'S PSYCHIATRIC
DIAGNOSIS WHEN EVALUATING IF THE
DEFENDANT IS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL AND ELIGIBLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
HOWEVER, INDIVIDUALS WITH
BORDERLINE PERSONALITY DISORDER
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THESE
PROVISIONS. THE EXCLUSION IN
EXISTING LAW PERPETUATES HARMFUL
STIGMA ABOUT THE DISORDER AND
LIMITS ACCESS TO NECESSARY
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. AB 1377
WILL INCREASE EQUITY WITHIN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH BORDERLINE PERSONALITY
DISORDER AND HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. WE HAVE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN AYE, GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLEY DODD. AYE. RAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. NO GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO. JOBO.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GILL.
NO MINETA. NO. DALLEY. NO GROVE.
NO LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYES 28.
NOES 11. MEASURE PASSES. THE
NEXT THREE UP ARE 375, 381 AND
383. SENATOR ASHBY IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 375.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2426 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2426 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. 2426 WOULD REQUIRE
THE SALE OF DIGITAL GOODS SUCH
AS MOVIES, TV SHOWS AND VIDEO
GAMES TO INCLUDE AN EXPLICIT
DISCLOSURE THAT THE PURCHASER IS
ONLY RECEIVING A LICENSE TO
ACCESS THAT ITEM. AB 2426
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE OF
MISINFORMATION BY REQUIRING
THOSE SELLERS TO INCREASE THEIR
TRANSPARENCY ON THESE
TRANSACTIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 375. ALAN A GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY.
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MILO. OKOBO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH VÌ. RUBIO AYE. STELLATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. A SMALL FAVORS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER GROVE. NO MCGUIRE. MIN
AYE. NGUYEN MILO. CHOBOQ SENATOR
ASHBY MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
ALAN, YOU HAVE NEXT. TWO BILLS
ARE YOURS. SENATOR. ALAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
381. ASSEMBLY BILL 2643 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD. AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
ALAN, MEMBERS ILLICIT CANNABIS
CULTIVATION POSES A REALLY
ENORMOUS THREAT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECOSYSTEM AND NATURAL RESOURCES,
PARTICULARLY THROUGH LARGE SCALE
HABITAT DESTRUCTION AND
CONSTRUCTION OF UNAUTHORIZED
ROADS AND RESERVOIRS, AND
IMPACTS ON ON WATER. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES,
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
FANTASTIC. SENATOR ELLEN, ANY
DISCUSSION? THIS DOES REQUIRE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. I.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. WAYNE. AYE. MILO AYE.
OKOBOJI AYE. PODIUM. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR ALLEN
MOVES THE CALL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 383.
ASSEMBLY BILL 660 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND ACT RELATING TO
FOOD AND BEVERAGE PRODUCTS.
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS FOR TOO
LONG, CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN
MISLED BY UNCLEAR LABELS ON FOOD
STORES OFFER PRODUCTS WITH SUCH
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT DATES
LABELS LIKE EXPIRES ON BEST
BEFORE, ENJOY, BUY, SELL, BUY,
TO NAME A FEW. SO THESE LABELS
END UP MISLEADING AND CONFUSING
CONSUMERS, WITH ONE STUDY
ATTRIBUTING AS MUCH AS 20% OF
FOOD WASTE TO THESE LABELS ALONE.
THE IDEA OF THIS BILL IS TO END
THAT CONFUSION. IT TAKES THE
INDUSTRY'S OWN ADOPTED STANDARD
AND REQUIRES FOOD ITEMS THAT USE
DATE LABELS TO USE STANDARD
TERMS BEST IF USED BY TO
INDICATE THE QUALITY DATE OF
FOOD OR USE BY TO INDICATE THE
SAFETY OF THE FOOD. THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
INCORPORATED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM CDFA AND CDFW,
ENSURING THAT THE BILL IN FRONT
OF YOU IS NOW ONE THAT OUR STATE
CAN IMPLEMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS COMFORTABLE
WITH. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. I
SEE NO MIKES UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKESBURG.
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DAWLEY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. TROBO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROD. AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK HI. SENATOR ALLEN
MOVES THE CALL. NEXT THREE ON
DECK ARE FILED. ITEM 385, 407
AND 415. SENATOR ASHBY HAS FILED
ITEM 385. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 51 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND ACT RELATING TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD, CHILDCARE AND
EDUCATION. SENATOR ASHBY. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I AM VERY PROUD TO
RISE TO PRESENT AB 51, THE CHILD
CARE STABILIZATION ACT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN MIA BONTA, AB
51 SUPPORTS FUNDING COMMUNITY
CHILDCARE AND INCREASES ACCESS
TO CALIFORNIA'S STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AB 51 IS A WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GÒM AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE. MILO AYE.
COBO AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE SENATOR ASHBY MOVES THE
CALL. SENATOR BRADFORD IS NOT
HERE. HAS FILED ITEM 407.
YEAH. SENATOR BRADFORD IS
PREPARED FOR FILE ON 407.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. THANK
YOU, MR. Ó. ASSEMBLY BILL 3131
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN
ACT RELATING TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR. MADAM PRESIDENT.
AB 3131 ON BEHALF OF MCCARTY AND
PRESENTING AS PART OF THE CLBC
REPARATIONS BILL PACKAGE, AB
3131 WILL ENSURE THAT CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
BETTER SERVE BLACK STUDENTS BY
GRANTING POSITIVE CONSIDERATION
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS ELIGIBLE FOR
EQUITY MULTIPLIER FUNDING,
ACCESS TO THE EQUITY. I'M SORRY,
ACCESS TO QUALITY CTE PROGRAMS
IS NOT ALWAYS EQUITABLE. IN
FACT, BLACK STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM HIGH
QUALITY VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS. THE
CENTER FOR AMERICAN PROGRESS
NOTES THAT SCHOOLS WOULD
REGULARLY PLACE BLACK STUDENTS
INTO LOW QUALITY VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. AS AN EXTENSION OF JIM
CROW ERA SEGREGATION. THE
CALIFORNIA REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE FINAL REPORT FOUND THAT
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HIGHER
QUALITY CTE PROGRAMS FOR BLACK
STUDENTS IS VIABLE IS A VITAL
STEP IN CLOSING THE EXISTING GAP
IN EDUCATION. AB 3131 IS GEARED
TO HELP STUDENTS WHO NEED ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CTE PROGRAMS THE
MOST. THIS BILL IS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR. FORM
407. ANY DISCUSSION? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
AYE. RODA-GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. TROBO
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES A CALL.
SENATOR HURTADO, YOU ARE UP NEXT
FOR ITEM 4.15. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2786 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT
RELATING TO CERTIFIED MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
HURTADO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2786 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. AB 2786
ESTABLISHES A PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO UTILIZE THEIR
WORK BENEFITS AT CERTIFIED
MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS, WHICH
SUPPORTS THE CONSUMPTION OF
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THROUGH
THE WILK FARMERS MARKET.
NUTRITION PROGRAM AND MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS. BRING FARM
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNITIES THAT
OTHERWISE LACK ACCESS.
CURRENTLY, MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS ARE NOT AUTHORIZED TO
REDEEM WHHIC BENEFITS. TO
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY, AB 2786
DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST, IT
CODIFIES CERTIFIED MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS INTO STATE LAW.
AND SECOND, IT DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
INCLUDE CERTIFIED MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS IN THE STATE PLAN, WHICH
THEY SUBMIT ANNUALLY TO
PARTICIPATE IN WHHIC. IF THE
STATE PLAN IS APPROVED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE D.P.H. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ESTABLISH CRITERIA TO AUTHORIZE
CERTIFIED FARMERS MARKETS TO
PARTICIPATE IN WILK BY ALLOWING
BY ALLOWING WILK PARTICIPANTS TO
USE THEIR BENEFITS AT CERTIFIED
MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS. THIS
BILL WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS FOOD FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I RESPECT
AND I VOTE THOSE MY COLLEAGUES.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU I SUPPORT
SUPPORT, I APOLOGIZE. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN. Ã. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZO I EGGMAN, I GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
O'DONNELL. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. MILO. AYE
JACOBO. AYE. PODIUM PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR HURTADO
MOVES TO MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
SERATO FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU
RISE? FOR THE NEXT BILL. NO, YOU
ARE NOT UP, SIR. NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM 417, 418 AND 419. SENATOR
CUEVAS, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
FIVE 417. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL, 1986 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRISONS. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1986 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN, WHICH REQUIRES THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
MAINTAIN ON ITS WEBSITE A
CENTRALIZED LIST OF DISAPPROVED
OR BANNED BOOKS FOR AMENDMENTS.
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL BY
REMOVING PROVISIONS THAT SET
MANDATES FOR CDCR. THIS BILL IS
A PRODUCT OF THE CALIFORNIA
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE REPORT
AND IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
BLACK CAUCUS REPARATIONS
PACKAGE. IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION? FILE ITEM 417.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN AYE. I'LL GO. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKESBERG
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. TALLEY. AYE.
DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE POTATO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE OKUBO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SEMIQUAVERS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. SENATOR SMALLWOOD,
CUERVOS MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
SUGIARTO, I APOLOGIZE. YOU GOT
MISINFORMATION BEFORE, BUT IT IS
YOUR TURN NOW FOR FILE ITEM 418.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE.
PASS ON FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ FILE. ITEM 418. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1843 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR
SATO. AYE. ONE. TWO. THREE.
FOUR. FIVE. OKAY. GOT THEM ALL.
IT IS A SUPPORT. SUPPORT. SIX.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 1843 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. THIS BILL
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE AND
EXPAND THE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO OUR
EMS WORKERS IN PRIVATE AMBULANCE
COMPANIES. THIS BILL HAS NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATORS, THIS
REQUIRES A 4/5 VOTE. THAT IS 32
VOTES. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKESBERG.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY AYE.
DODD AYE. DURAZO I. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
HI. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OJOBO AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER A
SMALL CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR SATO
MOVES A CALL. SENATOR CABALLERO,
YOU HAVE FILED ITEM 419.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2430 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ. AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SENATOR CABALLERO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB 2430. TODAY, ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ. THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT
A LOCAL DEVELOPER FROM PAYING AN
EXTRA UNNECESSARY MONITORING FEE
ON A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT. ALL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
RECEIVE STATE FUNDS ARE SUBJECT
TO COMPLIANCE MONITORING. THAT
MEANS THAT THEY DETERMINE
WHETHER THE INCOME LEVEL OF THE
INHABITANTS IS CORRECT, AND TO
ENSURE THE DEVELOPMENT MEETS
HABITABILITY STANDARDS, THAT
DUPLICATION OF A MONITORING FEE
ADDS UNNECESSARY COST TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WE GOT
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. OKAY,
THEN WE'LL CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
419. ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE. RAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. AYE. MILO AYE.
OKUBO. AYE PODIUM. PORTANTINO
HI. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. ACIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE EGGMAN. AYE CALL THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. PADILLA. SEN.
CABALLERO MOVES THE CALL NOW.
MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
420. SUSAN SENATOR EGGMAN, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2613 BY SOME
MEMBERS. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AB 2613
CREATES A RARE DISEASE ADVISORY
COUNCIL IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
CREATED IN THE MEMORY OF
JACQUELINE MARIE ZUBER. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SISTER WHO
ENDURED A THREE YEAR BATTLE OF
ALS, ALSO KNOWN AS LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE. THIS BILL WILL BE NAMED
IN HER HONOR. I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI, GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY
AYE. DODD. AYE AYE. TERRAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. MILO AYE. JOBO
PADILLA. PORTANTINO HI. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. STELLATO AYE.
SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILHELM.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR EGGMAN MOVES TO CALL
NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 422. SENATOR
ELLENBERG, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2946 BY MEMBER
VALENCIA. AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES. THIS BILL
BY SOME MEMBER VALENCIA COULD
NOT BE MORE TIMELY. THOSE OF US
IN ORANGE COUNTY ARE WELL AWARE
OF THE SCANDAL THAT IS BREWING
CONCERNING THE DISPENSE OF
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS AND THE LACK
OF ACCOUNTABILITY. SEARCH
WARRANTS HAVE BEEN EXECUTED
ACROSS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENTS, AS WELL
AS THE HOMES OF ONE OF THE
SUPERVISORS, IN CONNECTION WITH
THE POTENTIAL MISUSE AND
MISAPPROPRIATION OF TAXPAYER
FUNDS. WHAT AB 2946 AIMS TO DO
IS IT AIMS TO REQUIRE THAT WHEN
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS ARE
DISPENSED, THAT THE BOARD MUST
ACTUALLY VOTE ON THE EXPENDITURE
OF THOSE DISCRETIONARY FUNDS, I
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY. YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. GILLUM. Ã
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY
AYE. DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENJIVAR. MEN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. MILO OKOBO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO SKINNER. A SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB VÌ. WIENER AYE. WILK
AYE. AYE GROVE. AYE SENATOR.
SENATOR. UMBERG MOVES THE CALL
NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM 388. SENATOR UMBERG, YOU'RE
UP. THREE. EIGHT. EIGHT.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3048. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. LOWENTHAL AND ACT
RELATING TO PRIVACY. SENATOR.
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. ASSEMBLY BILL
3048, AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL, WOULD GIVE
CONSUMERS AND PARENTS BETTER
ACCESS TO SIMPLE, POWERFUL TOOLS
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO EXERCISE
THEIR PRIVACY RIGHTS WITH
RESPECT TO WEBSITES AND APPS IN
A SINGLE STEP. URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR UMBERG, ANY
DISCUSSION ON ITEM 388?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NO. DODD AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NO. MILO OKOBO. PERDUE
A. NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO A.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
ASHBY. SENATOR UMBERG MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP ARE FIVE ITEMS.
427 AND 429. SENATOR ALAN HAS AS
AB 1775. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1775 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY AND ACT RELATING TO
CANNABIS. MEMBERS. SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
UNDER EXISTING LAW, LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ALLOWED TO
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ON THE PREMISES OF A
LICENSED CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
LOUNGE, BUT CURRENT STATE LAW
PREVENTS THESE LOUNGES FROM
PREPARING AND SELLING FRESHLY
MADE FOOD AND BEVERAGES, EVEN IF
THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTION WOULD
OTHERWISE ALLOW THEM TO. BY
LIMITING THEM TO PREPACKAGED
ITEMS LIKE CANDY OR BOTTLED
WATER, THIS HAS CREATED COSTLY
AND CUMBERSOME WORKAROUNDS TO
PROVIDE THEIR GUESTS WITH THE
EXPECTED EXPERIENCE BY EITHER
TAKING OUT TWO PROPERTY LEASES
OR HAVING FOOD ITEMS DELIVERED
IN FROM OUTSIDE VENDORS. SO THIS
BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ALLOW FOR THESE
LOUNGES TO PREPARE AND SERVE
FRESH MADE NON CANNABIS AND
NONALCOHOLIC FOODS. AND
BEVERAGES. IT IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE, AND THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
BY REQUIRING THE LOUNGES TO POST
WARNINGS THAT CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION WILL OCCUR ON THE
PREMISES. REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
INCLUDE SECONDHAND SMOKE IN
WORKPLACE HAZARD EVALUATIONS,
AND FOR THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
TO CONSIDER VENTILATION AND
FILTRATION REQUIREMENTS WITH
RESPECT, I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ALAN, ANY DISCUSSION ON
ITEM 427? SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALAN. AYE. I'LL
GO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY DODD.
AYE. DALLEY. AYE. TORAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
NO. MEN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO AYE. NO. PODIUM
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL
QUIVERS. AYE. STERN. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB NO. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR ALLEN MOVES THE CALL.
SENATOR UMBERG, YOU HAVE ITEM
429. YOU ARE READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL, 2023
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING
ELEMENTS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU. MR. EXCUSE ME, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND COLLEAGUES, THIS
BILL CREATES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF INVALIDITY IN ANY
LEGAL ACTION CHALLENGING A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT'S ACTION OR FAILURE
TO ACT. IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINDS THAT THE
ACTION OR FAILURE TO ACT DOES
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLY WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT'S ADOPTED
HOUSING ELEMENT OR HOUSING
ELEMENT OBLIGATIONS. URGENT I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR UMBERG.
I SEE NO DISCUSSION ON THE
MATTER. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DAWLEY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MEN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. WAYNE NO. NILO NO.
BOCOBO NO. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROBB RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER A SMALL QUAVERS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. GROVE.
NO. OKAY. MEMBERS. SENATOR
UMBERG MOVES A CALL FOR MEMBERS.
A LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING. CAN WE
GET EVERYONE'S ATTENTION FOR
JUST A MOMENT, PLEASE? SHH WE'VE
COMPLETED OVER 90 BILLS. THANKS
TO OUR WONDERFUL PRESIDING
OFFICER. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
DINNER BREAK FOR AN HOUR AROUND
5:00, SO WE'RE GOING TO WORK UP
UNTIL THAT AT THAT POINT. BUT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE COMMITTEES
DURING THE DINNER HOUR. MEMBERS,
CAN YOU ALL HEAR THAT? MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A DINNER BREAK AT 5:00, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE COMMITTEES
THAT ARE GOING TO MEET DURING
THAT TIME. SO BE AWARE OF THAT
FACT. WE'RE ASKING MEMBERS TO
PLEASE STAY IN THE BUILDING SO
WE CAN RESUME OUR BILL WORKLOAD
TONIGHT AND MAKE GREAT PROGRESS
ON OUR IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US. EVERYBODY
GOOD ON THAT. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
430. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2995.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2995 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AB 2995 WOULD
MAKE CHANGES TO TERMINOLOGY IN
EXISTING LAW TO REMOVE
STIGMATIZING LANGUAGE FOR PEOPLE
SEEKING ALCOHOL OR DRUG
TREATMENT SERVICES, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR NHIÀU. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WE CANNOT.
NO, WE DON'T HAVE TO CALL THE
ROLL. ALL RIGHT. IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN. BUT WE HAVE MEMBERS OFF
THE FLOOR. ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY,
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE OH,
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD BY
CABALLERO. BY CORTEZ. DALLY. I
DODD. BY DURAZO. I. EGGMAN I
GLAZER. WE ARE. AYE. GONZALEZ. I
GROVE I HURTADO. JONES. I LAIRD,
I LOWMAN. I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I
MIN I NEWMAN. I WAYNE. I NILO I
OCHOA I PADILLA. YEAH. WE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SATO I SKINNER. I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN, I UMBERG, I WAHAB, I
WIENER, I WILK I SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVES THE. NEXT THREE
ON FILE ARE FOUND ON 436 440 AND
448. SENATOR WIENER, YOU HAVE
FIRED ON 436. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2376 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAYNES. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
SENATOR WIENER, I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2376 ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR BAYNES. IT PROVIDES MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS TO EXPAND CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCY RECOVERY SERVICES AND
ALLOWS FOR PATIENTS TO BEGIN
LONG TERM ADDICTION TREATMENT IN
A HOSPITAL SETTING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. DO WE HAVE
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALDA. AURORA. GIL. HI.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLY.
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO. AYE.
SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. SEN
WIENER MOVES A CALL. SENATOR
ALLEN, YOU'RE ON DECK. YOU HAVE
FIVE ITEM FOR 40. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3216
BY SOME MEMBER. HOOVER. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUPILS. SENATOR
ALLEN. MEMBERS. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ADOPT
POLICIES BY JULY OF 2026 TO
LIMIT OR PROHIBIT THE USE OF
SMARTPHONES BY STUDENTS DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY. WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT SMARTPHONE USAGE BY
CHILDREN IS ASSOCIATED WITH POOR
MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES, ANXIETY,
DEPRESSION, HIGHER RATES OF
SUICIDE AMONGST TEENS. A STUDY
FROM 2016 FOUND THAT WHEN
SMARTPHONES WERE REMOVED FROM
CLASSROOMS, TEST SCORES
INCREASED BY AN AVERAGE OF 6%,
WITH EVEN GREATER IMPROVEMENTS
AMONG LOW ACHIEVING STUDENTS,
ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, WHICH ALREADY HAVE
LIMITED SMARTPHONE USE, REPORT
INCREASED SOCIAL INTERACTION
AMONG PEERS, DECREASED INSTANCES
OF BULLYING ON CAMPUS,
IMPROVEMENTS IN ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
THE LIMITATIONS ON SMARTPHONES
IN SCHOOLS STATEWIDE IN ORDER TO
LIMIT HARMFUL EFFECTS DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY. IT DOES NOT
PRESCRIBE WHAT TYPE OF POLICY A
DISTRICT MUST PASS, BUT IT
ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY FOR EACH
DISTRICT TO CHOOSE THE APPROACH
THAT WORKS BEST FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ALLEN, FOR
THE SUPPORT. SUPPORT SPEECH. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE. Þ ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. I'LL VOTE TO
GO. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
NO. ATKINS. INTERESTING BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE.
AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
OTERO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. WAYNE AYE.
NILO. AYE COBO. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. BY ROD. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. GRAVERT. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER WILK. SENATOR ALLEN MOVES
A CALL. TO SECRETARY. WE
CAPTURED THAT LAST VOTE. ATKINS.
ATKINS. AYE SENATOR ALLEN MOVES
THE CALL. SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU
HAVE FILE ITEM 448. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2667
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SANTIAGO. AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AB 226 BY ASSEMBLYMAN
SANTIAGO WOULD STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA'S AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING, BETTER
KNOWN AS AFE LAW, BY PROVIDING
STAKEHOLDERS WITH MORE TOOLS TO
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
TAKING MEANINGFUL ACTION TO
FURTHER FAIR HOUSING. AB 2667
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP STANDARDS.
STANDARDIZED REPORTING FORMAT
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE DRAFT INVENTORY OF SITES
AVAILABLE, AND REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DISCLOSE THE
NUMBER OF UNITS APPROVED OR
DISAPPROVED IN THEIR ANNUAL
REPORTS. THESE CHANGES WOULD
ENSURE STAKEHOLDER STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO EVALUATE
JURISDICTIONS PROPOSALS AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA POINTS
TO ASSESS WHETHER OR AND TO WHAT
EXTENT THESE PROPOSED PROGRAMS
AND ACTIONS ARE ADVANCING.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND CHOICE
THROUGHOUT THE JURISDICTION, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BRADFORD. I
SEE NO MICS UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALL VOTED AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
EBCLC. NO. PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
NO. SKINNER. AYE SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN BY UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES THE CALL.
ALL RIGHT. HERE'S THE GREAT
NEWS. WE FINISHED ALL SIX PAGES
THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO DO OF
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
ANOTHER LIST TO GO THROUGH. THE
OTHER BAD NEWS IS WE STILL HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. SO STILL
PUTTING BILLS ON CALL.
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH MORE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READINGS. THESE
ARE THE NEXT THREE ON DECK FIVE.
ITEM ONE 3149 AND 190. SENATOR
SKINNER, YOU HAVE FILE ITEM 130.
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP FORWARD ON
149 FOR NOW. BUT SENATOR
SKINNER, YOU ARE UP WITH ITEM
130 A B 2632. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2632 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MEMBERS AND MADAM PRESIDENT AB
2632 WILL HELP CALIFORNIA REACH
ITS WEIGHT WASTE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING GOALS AND PROHIBIT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM ENACTING
OR ENFORCING BANS ON THRIFT
STORES THAT ARE NOT PLACED ON
OTHER RETAIL STORES. WITH THAT,
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. I SEE NO
MIKES UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO OCHOA. BOGH. AYE.
PERDUE PORTANTINO BY RA. AYE.
RUBIO SERRATO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALL CANVAS. STERN BY
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. NÓ. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE NIELSEN. NO. PADILLA.
AYE. SENATORS, WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE RIGHT NOW RESPECTFULLY
ASKING THAT YOU STAY IN THE
CHAMBER SO WE CAN GO THROUGH THE
VOTES. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. ALVARADO
GILMAN. MCGUIRE RUBIO. I
MOORLACH RIVAS. I AYES 36. NOES
TWO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE FOR
ITEM ONE, 91, 95 AND 200. SEN.
NEWMAN, YOU HAVE ITEM 190.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2093 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND AQUILINA. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SEN. NEWMAN. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO TO PRESENT AB 2093,
WHICH WILL EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM TO
ENABLE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
WAIVE ENROLLMENT FEES FOR ALL
FULL TIME STUDENTS PURSUING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, WHICH OFFERS ONE. AB
2093 HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO. I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION I'M SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OAN AYE. ALL VOTED AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBURG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NILO OKOBO. AYE. PERDUE AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SATO SKINNER. A SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE. OUR VICTORY WAS SHORT
LIVED. WE'RE PLACING BILLS BACK
ON CALL. SEN. NEWMAN MOVES THE
CALL. SEN. WILK, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 195. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2355 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARRILLO. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF 1974. SEN WILK. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMAN CARRILLO AND
ANNIE, I PRESENT AB 2355, WHICH
REQUIRES A DISCLOSURE WHEN AI IS
USED IN POLITICAL ADVERTISING BY
A STATE REGISTERED CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE TO SUBSTANTIALLY ALTER
EXISTING MEDIA OR CREATE
CONTENT. AI TECHNOLOGY IS
QUICKLY BECOMING MORE REALISTIC,
CHEAPER AND USER FRIENDLY
WITHOUT REASONABLE AND MEASURED
REGULATIONS. AI GENERATED
CONTENT COULD UNNECESSARILY
COMPLICATE OUR ELECTIONS WITH
BELIEVABLE BUT MISLEADING
INFORMATION. ALL OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED AND THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THIS REQUIRES A 27
VOTES. SENATORS, ANY DISCUSSION?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. RODRIGO. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. MILO. AYE THEY'RE ALL JUST
GOING OFF. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL FAVORS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR. WILK
MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR NEWMAN,
YOU HAVE FOR ITEM 200. FIREARM
200, AB 2565. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2565 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL FACILITIES.
SEN. NEWMAN THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2565,
WHICH WILL SAFEGUARD THE SAFETY
OF STUDENTS AND STAFF BY
REQUIRING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
INSTALL INTERIOR LOCKS AS PART
OF NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. AS
YOU KNOW, GUN VIOLENCE REMAINS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN IN AMERICA, SURPASSING
ANY OTHER TYPE OF INJURY OR
ILLNESS. IN 2023, THERE WERE 346
SCHOOL SHOOTING INCIDENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, MEANING THAT THE
U.S. AVERAGED NEARLY ONE SCHOOL
SHOOTING INCIDENT EVERY DAY. THE
SANDY HOOK COMMISSION, WHICH WAS
CONVENED IN 2012 TO REVIEW THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING THAT TRAGICALLY
TOOK 26 LIVES, HAS STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED THE INSTALLATION OF
INTERIOR LOCKS AT ALL SCHOOLS.
ALTHOUGH NOT A SINGLE LOCK DOOR
HAS EVER BEEN BREACHED DURING A
SCHOOL SHOOTING, 25% OF SCHOOLS
STILL DO NOT HAVE INTERIOR LOCKS,
REQUIRING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
INSTALL INTERIOR LOCKS AS PART
OF FUTURE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY OF GETTING
THIS DONE. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO NO VOTES TO DATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OAN. AYE. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE DODD. AYE DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. OR,
DATO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OKOBO AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE SEN.
NEWMAN MOVES A CALL. THE NEXT
THREE ARE ON DECK. FILE OR FILE.
ITEM TWO. OH THREE 233 AND 281
SEN. DOLLY IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 203.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2854 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN AND ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION. SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2854 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKIE IRWIN, AB
2854 WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED
ACCOUNTABILITY TO LOCAL SALES
TAX REVENUES. HOW THEY'RE
ALLOCATED OVER THE YEARS, SOME
CITIES HAVE BENEFITED
DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY ENTERING
INTO AGREEMENTS WITH VARIOUS
BUSINESSES. WHILE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES CITIES TO POST SOME
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITES
RELATED TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INCENTIVES, IT IS CURRENTLY
UNKNOWN HOW MANY SALES TAX
REBATE AGREEMENTS ARE IN PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA. HOW MUCH IS BEING
REBATED ANNUALLY, OR WHETHER
THESE EXPENDITURES OF CRITICAL
PUBLIC RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY
PRODUCING THE BENEFITS THEY WERE
PROMISED. WHILE AB 2854 DOES NOT
CHANGE ANY CITY'S ABILITY TO
ENTER INTO SUCH AGREEMENT, IT
WILL REQUIRE CITIES THAT HAVE
THESE AGREEMENTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION SO
THAT THE POLICYMAKERS AT THE
LEVELS CAN MAKE BETTER INFORMED
DECISIONS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR DALY.
ANY MEMBER WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. I'LL
RODA-GIL. NO. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE HAGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN MELO. NO. OKOBO. NØ.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER
A SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. SENATOR
DAWLEY MOVES THE CAR, CHANGING
UP THE ORDER THAT I GAVE YOU
PREVIOUSLY. I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE NEXT FIVE BILLS THAT'S
GOING TO BE FILED. ITEM 233
THREE 5365, 423 AND 442. SENATOR
ASHBY HAS FILED ITEM 233.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 977 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
SENATOR ASHBY. MADAM PRESIDENT,
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 977 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AB 977 WILL INCREASE
THE PENALTY FOR COMMITTING
ASSAULT AND BATTERY AGAINST
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT A HEALTH CARE
WORKER CAN EXPECT TO BE
THREATENED AT LEAST FOUR TIMES
AND ASSAULTED AT LEAST ONCE A
YEAR. AS A RESULT, ONE THIRD OF
EMERGENCY NURSES HAVE CONSIDERED
LEAVING THEIR JOBS DUE TO
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE. THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH PARITY,
ENCOURAGE EMERGENCY WORKERS TO
REPORT INCIDENTS, CHANGE THE
NOTION THAT WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
IS PART OF THEIR JOB. CURRENT
LAWS PROTECT PUBLIC SERVANTS
SUCH AS FIREFIGHTERS, POLICE
OFFICERS, EMTS AND PARAMEDICS,
WHICH I WOULD POINT OUT ARE MALE
DOMINATED PROFESSIONS. HOWEVER,
OUR HOSPITAL WORKERS,
PREDOMINANTLY NURSES, WHICH I
WOULD POINT OUT IS A FEMALE
DOMINANT PROFESSION, DO NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME PROTECTION.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT A JUDGE
MAINTAINS PROSECUTION DISCRETION
IN CASES WHERE A PATIENT
EXPERIENCE A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS, ASSAULTS AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEE. AB 977 WILL
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE WORKERS THE
RESPECT THEY DESERVE, WHILE
PROTECTING THEM FROM WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ASHBY. I AM
SEEING NO MIXUP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. I'LL RODRIGO. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DELI AYE. DODD DURAZO. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE. SENATOR ASHBY
MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A QUICK PAUSE.
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
STRETCH, STAND UP, MOVE OUR
LIMBS.
I HOPE YOU HAD A GOOD STRETCH,
SENATOR SKINNER. WE'RE COMING
BACK. SENATOR SKINNER, YOU HAVE
FIVE. ITEM 350. AB 2697.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2697 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB 2697
DEALS WITH THE ISSUE OF OUR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGERS THAT
ARE INSTALLED WITH OUR STATE
GRANT AND TAXPAYER MONEY. WHAT?
2697 DOES IS REQUIRES OUR ENERGY
COMMISSION TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
SO THAT DRIVERS CAN ACCESS A
WORKING EV CHARGER USING THEIR
PREFERRED APP SO THEY CAN KNOW
IN ADVANCE WHAT WHICH ARE
WORKING. ROAMING ALLOWS DRIVERS
TO CHARGE SEAMLESSLY WITHOUT
USING MULTIPLE APPS AND
SUBSCRIPTIONS. CHARGERS WILL BE
STRANDED ASSETS IF DRIVERS CAN'T
LOCATE FUNCTIONAL CHARGING
STATIONS. THE OPPOSITION THAT
WAS THERE BEFORE IS MOVED NOW TO
A SUPPORT POSITION. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SO
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL. ON
A RODA-GIL BY ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY
AYE. DALY DODD. AYE DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. BY MEN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. WAYNE AYE. NILO AYE.
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO SKINNER. A
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR SKINNER
MOVES A CALL. PARKER IS ON CALL.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU HAVE FIVE.
ITEM 365. WE ARE ON AB 2724.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2724 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. AN ACT RELATING TO HIGH
SCHOOL PUPILS. SEN. NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELOISE REYES TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2724, WHICH WILL
PROVIDE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO PREREGISTER
TO VOTE BY THE END OF 11TH
GRADE. ALTHOUGH 16 AND 17 YEAR
OLDS IN CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PRE-REGISTER
TO VOTE, ONLY 11% OF 16 AND 17
YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY
PREREGISTERED. AB 2724 WILL
FACILITATE VOTER
PRE-REGISTRATION IN CALIFORNIA
BY AFFORDING HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRE-REGISTER AT THEIR SCHOOL
SITE. THIS BILL WILL DIRECT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE THAT EACH OF ITS PUPILS
RECEIVES INFORMATION ON HOW TO
PROPERLY PRE-REGISTER TO VOTE AT
LEAST ONCE BEFORE THE COMPLETION
OF 11TH GRADE. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES, I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR. I
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. SEN.
NEWMAN NO ONE HAS. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HAPPENED? ALLEN HI, GIL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD. AYE. D'ORAZIO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. OR
DATO. AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OKOBO
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMOKERS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'LL GO.
CABALLERO AYE. JONES LOCKE.
MCGUIRE OKOBO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. NO 365. AYE DOLLY.
DOLLY. AYE. TO NO. D¯ÚI.
PORTANTINO. AYE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME. I'LL GO. JONES
MCGUIRE. OKOBO. PADILLA WILK. I
DON'T KNOW. PADILLA. GROVE. I
DON'T KNOW. QUICK PAUSE.
SENATOR NEWMAN MOVES. FILE ITEM
365. SEN. NEWMAN MOVES THE CALL.
SENATOR ASHBY, YOU HAVE FIRED ON
423. BEFORE YOU BEGIN, SENATORS,
SOME HOUSEKEEPING RULES. WE HAVE
A FULL HOUSE. THE DOORS ARE
LOCKED. WE ARE STICKING HERE. WE
HAVE TWO BILLS TO GET THROUGH
FOR. RIGHT NOW. FOUND ON 423.
SENATOR ASHBY. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3252 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT
RELATING TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR. SENATOR
ASHBY. MADAM PRESIDENT, I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 3252 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. THIS IS
THE SUNSET BILL FOR COURT
REPORTERS BOARD, WHICH REGULATES
COURTROOM STENOGRAPHERS AND
DEPOSITION REPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I SEE NO MIKES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS REQUIRES 27 VOTES. ALLEN
AYE. I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI
AYE. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE. OR.
DATO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN. AYE. NEUMANN AYE. WAYNE
MILO. AYE OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROD BY
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL FAVORS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES.
MCGUIRE. WAYNE. AYES 37. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE. AYES 37. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR CORTEZ HAS FOULED OUT ON
442. HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3061
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAYNIE. AN
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES RISE TO
PRESENT AB 3061. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HAYNIE. THE BILL
ENACTS STATUTORY MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS FOR DATA COLLECTION
REGARDING THE TESTING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES. SPECIFICALLY, IT
REQUIRES REPORTING AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE COLLISIONS.
DISENGAGEMENTS IMMOBILIZATION,
AND TRAFFIC CITATIONS BASED ON A
SPECIFIC TIME FRAME. THERE'S A
STRONG PUBLIC INTEREST IN AB
DATA TRANSPARENCY, AND BY
MANDATING CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR
DATA COLLECTION AND SHARING,
THIS BILL PROMOTES SAFETY,
INNOVATION AND TRUST IN
TECHNOLOGY, AND THIS LAW WILL
ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY AMONG
MANUFACTURERS AND EMPOWER USERS
TO MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE
NO MIX UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI. I'LL TRY
TO GO. NØ. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. OTOBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NØ SKINNER.
AYE. SMOKE. RIVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLEY
GROVE. NO MCGUIRE. NGUYEN OKOBO.
DALLEY. NO AYES 30. NO SEVEN.
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT ON DECK IS
FIRE. ITEM 425. SENATOR PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2887 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL SAFETY. SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2087 FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NOW NAMED THE
HEATHER HEATHER ACT. ADDRESSES A
CRITICAL ISSUE BY MANDATING THAT
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS INCLUDE DETAILED
PROCEDURES FOR SCHOOL PERSONNEL
TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY TO SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST OR OTHER LIFE
THREATENING MEDICAL EMERGENCIES
ON SCHOOL GROUNDS. IT FURTHER
ENCOURAGES CPR TRAINING AND
STRATEGIC AD PLACEMENT IN THESE
PROCEDURES. THE BILL HAS BROAD
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM FIVE? ITEM 425.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. RODRIGO. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
O'DONNELL AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
HÌNH AYES 39. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE HAVE SEVEN
BILLS COMING UP THAT ARE ALL
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. PLEASE STAY IN THE
BUILDING. SO WE CAN. SO THEY CAN
BE ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WE HAVE FIVE ITEM 281 300
AND 307. SENATOR NEWMAN FOR
FIVE. ITEM 281. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2473
BY COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION AND
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEY HAVE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2473, WHICH IS AN ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL, WHICH DOES THREE THINGS.
ONE, IT ALLOWS TEACHERS TO EARN
AUTHORIZATIONS TO TEACH
ADDITIONAL SUBJECTS BY
DEMONSTRATING SUBJECT MATTER
COMPETENCE. TWO REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING TO RECOGNIZE
AUTHORIZATIONS EARNED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ENSURES
CONTINUED ACCESS TO FEDERAL
CRIMINAL HISTORY, CRIMINAL
HISTORY INFORMATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS EMPLOYED OR SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT AT THE CTC. I AM
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING, AND I
VOTE TODAY. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? THIS
REQUIRES 27 VOTES. IT HAS AN
URGENCY CLAUSE. SENATOR PADILLA,
DO YOU WISH? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES
39. WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 39.
NÓ ZERO. SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU
HAVE THE NEXT TWO BILLS FOR ITEM
300. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1884 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUPIL ATTENDANCE. THANK YOU
AGAIN, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD TO PRESENT AB 1884, WHICH
MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES TO
CALIFORNIA'S ED CODE REGARDING
EXCUSED ABSENCES FOR STUDENTS
WITH MILITARY FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
DEPLOY. THIS MEASURE HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES TO DATE.
I AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. ANY
DISCUSSION? ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? AYES 39. NØ ZERO. MEASURE
MEASURE. PASSES. COMING OUT OF
LEFT FIELD, SENATOR NEWMAN IS
NOW TIED FOR FIRST PLACE. YOU
HAVE FIVE. ITEM 307. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2073
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
AND RELATING TO PEOPLE,
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU AGAIN,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2073 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. AB
2073 AUTHORIZES LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARDS TO
DIRECTLY APPROVE ALTERNATIVE
TERM SCHEDULES, PROVIDED THAT
ALL STATE PHYSICAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS CONTINUE TO BE MET.
THIS BILL HAS ALSO RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. I SEE NO MIX UP.
DO WE HAVE ANY OBJECTION FOR
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? NO OBJECTION. AYES 39,
NOES ZERO. NEXT THREE FIVE. ITEM
356 369 AND 424. SENATOR SKINNER
HAS FILED ITEM 356. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1053
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. AN
ACT RELATING TO HOUSING. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AB
1053 WILL LOWER FINANCIAL
BARRIERS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY ALLOWING
DEVELOPERS TO ACCESS HCD LOANS
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION PERIOD.
IT MAKES COMMON SENSE TO DO THIS
TO ALLOW THESE LOANS TO BE
DISTRIBUTED. WHILE CONSTRUCTION
IS UNDERWAY, BECAUSE IT WILL
SAVE MILLIONS IN INTEREST
RELATED COSTS. THE BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT DOES
NOT HAVE OPPOSITION. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM 356? ANY OBJECTION FOR
UTILIZING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
AYES 39. NO SIX. NO ZERO. AYES
39. NOES ZERO. MEASURE. PASSES
SENATOR BECKER HAS FILED ITEM
369. GO. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2681 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
WEAPONS. SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THE SAFE AND ETHICAL USE OF
ADVANCED ROBOTICS BY PROHIBITING
THE MANUFACTURE, SALE OR USE OR
OPERATION OF ROBOTIC DEVICE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? DO
WE HAVE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OAN Þ. RODEO AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD
DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAESER
GONZALEZ. VÌ. GROVE AYE. OR
DATO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE MENJIVAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEUMANN AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. MILO. AYE. OKUBO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
AYE. ARCHULETA DODD. GLAZER. AYE
JONES. AYE MCGUIRE. OKUBO AYE.
ROTH AYE. WAHAB AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ARCHULETA DODD. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYES 38. NØ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES TWO. MORE ON OUR
LIST BEFORE DINNER. SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS BOTH OF THEM FILED.
ITEM 424 IS UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2080
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA TO
PRESENT AB 2080. AB 2080 WILL
REQUEST THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
DATA ON EACH UC SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE TO BETTER TRACK
PROGRESS TOWARD DIVERSIFYING
THEIR MEDICAL SCHOOL CLASSES. AB
28 2080 HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES TO DATE. ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
I SEE NO MICS UP FOR DISCUSSION.
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES
39. NÓ ZERO. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THIS IS YOUR 10TH BILL. THE
RECORD SO FAR THIS WEEK. THANK
YOU. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE
ITEM 437. ASSEMBLY BILL 938 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. AN
ACT RELATING TO EDUCATION
FINANCE. SEN. NEWMAN. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL 938. AB 930 WILL REQUIRE
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE TO
REPORT THEIR PROGRESS IN CLOSING
THE WAGE GAP. EACH YEAR BETWEEN
TEACHERS AND OTHER SPECIFIED
PROFESSIONS, THEREBY PROVIDING
THE LEGISLATURE AND LEAS THE
DATA NEEDED TO HAVE THE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO FULLY
SOLVE OUR WORKFORCE. EDUCATOR
CHALLENGES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. ANY MEMBER
WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM?
ANYONE HAVE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? I SEE NONE. AYES 39. NO.
ZERO. THAT IS THE BILLS FOR NOW.
NOW MOVING INTO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR LEHMAN,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
HUMAN SERVICES WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM 113 UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. HOUSING COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT
IN ROOM 112. HERE IN THIS
BUILDING. THANK YOU. YOU ARE
SEN. GLAZER. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM PRESIDENT, SENATE REVENUE
AND TAXATION WILL MEET AFTER
HUMAN SERVICES IN ROOM 113.
EVERY SINGLE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT COMMITTEES ARE
OCCURRING DURING RECESS, NOT
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE IN RECESS
FOR DINNER FOR ONE HOUR. WE ARE
GOING TO BE RECONVENING AT 6
P.M, STAY IN THE BUILDING.
WE ARE BACK IN SESSION.
SENATORS. WELCOME BACK. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE BACK. WE HAVE TWO
FINAL ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO GO
OVER RIGHT NOW. AND ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING FOR ITEM. 226 AND
FILE ITEM 414, BOTH BY SENATOR
ATKINS. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FOR ITEM.
226 ASSEMBLY BILL 3013 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN
ACT RELATING TO COURTS. SENATOR
ATKINS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, ON THIS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT AB 3013 AUTHORIZES A ONE
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IN 13
COUNTIES TO STUDY THE USE OF
REMOTE COURT REPORTING, ACCURATE
COURT RECORDS ARE CRITICAL TO
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM, YET THERE
IS A GROWING SHORTAGE OF COURT
REPORTERS. WHILE MANY COURT
PROCEEDINGS HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
TAKE PLACE REMOTELY, COURT
REPORTERS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
COURTROOM IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY NEEDED TO PRODUCE AN
ACCURATE RECORD. AB 3013 ALLOWS
COURTS TO STUDY THE USE OF
REMOTE COURT REPORTING AND
REPORT BACK FINDINGS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO INFORM FUTURE
POLICY DECISIONS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM? THERE. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FOR ITEM 414.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2339 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDI-CAL. SENATOR
ATKINS. THANK YOU. SO I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2339 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE CAN
CURRENTLY ACCESS HEALTH CARE
THROUGH MOBILE APPS AND
MESSAGING, ALLOWING PATIENTS TO
MESSAGE WITH A DOCTOR ON THEIR
OWN SCHEDULE. MAKE HEALTH CARE
MORE ACCESSIBLE, ESPECIALLY FOR
WORKING FAMILIES. HOWEVER,
MEDI-CAL BENEFICIARIES CAN'T
ACCESS THESE TELEHEALTH SERVICES
UNLESS THEY MEET A LIST OF
SPECIFIC CONDITIONS. AB 2339
WOULD GIVE MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH FOR SENSITIVE
SERVICES VIA MESSAGING AND APPS,
INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS NARROW THIS
BILL TO SENSITIVE SERVICES ONLY.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DEL
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GROVE GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MELO. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO.
SKINNER AYE. A SMALL CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DAILY. GROVE JONES.
WAYNE. MILAM RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO.
AYES 34. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO DO A
QUICK TECHNICAL. CHECK, CHECK.
YES WE DID. SENATORS, WE'VE DONE
OVER 115 BILLS, BUT 51 OF THEM
ARE ON CALL. WE ARE NOW ENTERING
INTO THAT PHASE OF GOING THROUGH
THE 51 BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL.
YOU CANNOT LEAVE THE FLOOR
DURING THIS PROCESS. THANK YOU.
HERE WE GO. ARE WE READY? WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS. FILE ITEM 17.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. OF RODA-GIL.
CABALLERO. Ã DALI GROVE. JONES
MCGUIRE. Ã. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA.
RUBIO Ã. SATO. AYES 31. NOES
ONE. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM 18.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO, I.
DELHI GROVE. MCGUIRE Ã. NGUYEN
OKOBO. SERRATO AYES 34. NOES
ONE. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. FILE ITEM 19. OUR
LAST APPOINTMENT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO I. DELHI NØ GROVE. NØ
JONES. MCGUIRE. I AYES 31. NOES
EIGHT. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MOVING INTO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR FILE.
ITEM 103. DELHI MCGUIRE. I
NGUYEN. AYES 38. NÓ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
108. DELHI TERRAZZO I DELHI. I
MCGUIRE. I STERN I AYES 40 ZERO
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 109, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DELHI I
MCGUIRE. I STERN. I AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
IF THERE'S NO. CHAIR, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM
162. EGGMAN I MCGUIRE. I OKOBO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. EBCLC. AYES 31.
NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE PASSES.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE. ITEM 181. MR. BRADFORD.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. MCGUIRE I OKOBO.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. SEYARTO
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER. Ã.
WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BRADFORD
GLAZER. GONZALEZ OKOBO.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. SCIOTTO.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYES WIENER.
ITEM. NØ AYES 27. NOES FIVE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
184. CALLING A DODD. GLAZER. NØ
HURTADO. MCGUIRE I UMBERG I. I.
UMBERG. I DON'T KNOW. DODD NØ
DODD. NO AYES 25. NOES 14. THE
MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
256. LIMÓN I MCGUIRE. I. AYES
31. NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM 258.
BRADFORD Ã. LIMÓN I MCGUIRE. I
AYES 40. NØ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE. ITEM 156. ASHBY I DALLY
NÓ HURTADO I LIMON. I MCGUIRE. I
RUBIO. I STERN. I WILK NO. AYES
31. NOS EIGHT. MEASURE PASSES.
AYES 31. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO ITEM 282.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY. MCGUIRE DALLY. I MCGUIRE.
I STERN. I WILK I AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. ITEM 25.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL MCGUIRE. I NGUYEN.
OKOBO NØ. STERN I. AYES 31. NO
SEVEN MEASURE PASSES. IT'S
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM
289. I WROTE A GILL BECKER. I,
BLAKE SPEER. GROVE NO. MCGUIRE I
MIN I. STERN. I GILL. NO AYES
30. NOES N NOES NINE. IT'S A
LONG DAY. MEASURE PASSES.
PLEASE, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 290. BECKER
I GROVE I, LIMON. MCGUIRE I MIN
I STERN I AYES AYES. OH MY
GOODNESS. AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON 293 MR.
REPETITIVE. AND I'M GETTING SOME.
YEAH BECKER I, I CORTEZI I
GROVE. I MCGUIRE. I AYES 40 ZERO
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES ON TO FILE
ITEM 294. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER I GROVE I
MCGUIRE I AYES 40 NOES ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. ITEM 297. LET'S
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER
I DODD. GROVE I MCGUIRE. I MILO
I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DODD I
AYES 40 NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
FILE ITEM 299. BECKER I DODD I
LIMON. MCGUIRE I. PADILLA I.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. LIMÓN OKOBO. AYES
38. NÓ ZERO FIVE. ITEM 301.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER I DODD I MCGUIRE. I MIN I
UMBERG I AYES 40 NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM 306 IS
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER. I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I OCHOA BOGH
RUBIO. YES, I UMBERG I. AYES 31.
NOES EIGHT. MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM 309. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BLAKE. SPEER
CABALLERO. I GLAZER. GROVE NØ
MCGUIRE. I NEWMAN. PORTANTINO
RUBIO. I UMBERG I. AYES 25. NOES
TEN. MEASURE. PASSES WE'RE NOW
ON FILE ITEM 313. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER, BLAKE SPEER. DALLEY
DODD. GLAZER GONZALEZ. GROVE
GONZALEZ I GROVE. MCGUIRE I
NGUYEN. OKOBO UMBERG I. AYES 26.
NOES FIVE. MEASURE PASSES FOR
ITEM 316. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. BRADFORD I
MCGUIRE. I UMBERG I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE MORE
TIME. ALAN I AYES 40 NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES FIVE. ITEM 321.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE I UMBERG I. AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES FIVE. ITEM
324. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE. I UMBERG I.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE.
ITEM 325 AYES 40 NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES ON FILE ITEM 324.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE ITEM 325. HAUSER.
TERRAZZO I JONES. I MCGUIRE. I
STERN I UMBERG I AYES 40. NØ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 338.
JONES NØ MCGUIRE. I. RUBIO HI. A
PRO BONO. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I.
AYES 31. NOES NINE. MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM 375. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I,
MCGUIRE I NGUYEN. NILO MEASURE.
I DALLEY. I DON'T KNOW. AYES 33.
NOES FOUR. MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM 381. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER I, MCGUIRE I.
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM 383. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I
BRADFORD A DOLLY GLAZER I GROVE.
MCGUIRE I NGUYEN. HELLO OKOBO I
CIERTO. HI 34 NO. ONE MEASURE
PASSES. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE. ITEM 385. BECKER I,
GLAZER I LEMON I MCGUIRE I
PADILLA I AYES 40 NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 407.
BECKER I, MCGUIRE I, PADILLA I.
AYES 40. NØ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE. ITEM 415. BECKER I,
CABALLERO I, MCGUIRE I, PADILLA
I. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. WE HAVE 19 LEFT ON CALL.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
FILE. ITEM 417. BECKER I GROVE.
JONES I MCGUIRE. I NEWMAN.
GROVE. I NEWMAN I NGUYEN I OKOBO,
I UMBERG, I. AYES 40 ZERO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. ON.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
418. SENATOR WE NEED TO LIFT THE
CALL FOR SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I,
MCGUIRE. I PADILLA I AYES 40 NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
MOVING INTO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR A QUICK MINUTE.
SENATOR SERRATO, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION ON AB 1843.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM 418
AB 1843? SEEING NONE AYES 40 NØ
ZERO FOR RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 418 NØ.
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD TO FILE
ITEM 419. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR.
PADILLA I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
MENGIBAR I AYES 40 NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM 420.
CABALLERO I EGGMAN I MCGUIRE. I
MENGIBAR I OCHOA. I PADILLA I
AYES 40 ZERO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM 422. ALAN
CABALLERO I DODD. JONES MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NILO. PADILLA
I SATO. I DODD I. EYES 36. NØ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. LET'S CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
388. CABALLERO I, MCGUIRE I,
NEWMAN. MILO PADILLA. I. AYES
31. NOES SEVEN. MEASURE PASSES.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
FILE. ITEM 427. ASHBY ATKINS. I
OTERO. I DON'T KNOW. MCGUIRE I.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. RUBIO
STERN. I. AYES 30. NOES SEVEN.
MEASURE. PASSES LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 429.
ALAN ASHBY. BECKER CABALLERO.
DALLEY GLAZER. LEMON MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I PADILLA. I
PORTANTINO. I DON'T KNOW, MR.
THE SECRETARY IS GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. ROTH. STERN I
DON'T KNOW. RUBIO I DON'T KNOW.
GOING ONCE TWICE. DAILY. NO.
AYES 21. I AYES 21. NOS 12.
MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM 430.
COURTESY I HURTADO I MCGUIRE I,
PADILLA I. AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 436.
CORTEZ I MCGUIRE. I PADILLA I
RUBIO I WILK I AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM 440. CORTEZ I
TERRAZZO. MCGUIRE I PADILLA. I
WIENER I WILK I. AYES 38. NOES
ONE MEASURE PASSES EIGHT. LEFT
ON CALL. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE. ITEM 448. DALLEY
TERRAZZO GROVE. JONES MCGUIRE I
PADILLA. I JONES. NÓ I DON'T
KNOW. GROVE. NO AYES 30. NOES
EIGHT. MEASURE PASSES. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
190. GROVE MCGUIRE. I NGUYEN.
THREE. MILO I GROVE. I
PORTANTINO. I SEYARTO. AYES 37.
NÓ. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
195. ALAN I GROVE, I MCGUIRE. I
PORTANTINO I. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM 200.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES I
MCGUIRE I PORTANTINO I AYES 40
NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM 203. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JONES I, MCGUIRE I
NGUYEN PORTANTINO I. I 35 KNOWS
FOR MEASURE PASSES. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 233.
TERRAZZO JONES I LAIRD I,
MCGUIRE I PORTANTINO I. AYES 39.
NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE. ITEM
350. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK.
BRADFORD I DAWLEY. I GLAZER, I
JONES. I MCGUIRE. I PADILLA. I
PORTANTINO I SEYARTO I AYES 40
NÓ ZERO MEASURE PASSES LAST ONE
ON CALL FOR ITEM 365. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I
RODA-GIL NO JONES. NO MCGUIRE, I
OCHOA. BOGH. PADILLA I. AYES 31
KNOWS A MEASURE PASSES. WE DID
IT! I GET TO SAY OTHER WORDS
NOW. OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
MAJORITY LEADER, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THERE'S A
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE 61 FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILL 2243 TO
BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE.
THESE REQUESTS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR. SENATOR NIELLO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I OBJECT TO THIS MOTION
AND REQUEST A NO VOTE ON THE
FLOOR WHERE WE HAVE SOME
MAJORITY LEADERS REQUESTING AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR IS REQUESTING
A NO VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE 61 B BE
DISPENSED WITH. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN, I
GILL. NO. ARCHULETA I ASHBY. I
ATKINS, I BECKER. I BLAKE. SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLEY. NÓ DODD I DURAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO. HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN. I
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO COBO. NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SEYARTO NO. SKINNER I
SMALL. CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB. I WIENER I WILK. NO
PLEASE CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
MCGUIRE I AYES 31 NOES NINE. THE
JOINT RULES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED.
MAJORITY LEADER, YOU'RE ONCE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED. LET'S TRY THAT
AGAIN. MAJORITY LEADER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE THE
SENATE RULES. BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO AMEND
ASSEMBLY BILLS 180 AND 218.
THANK YOU, MAJORITY LEADER.
SENATOR NEIL, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
OBJECT TO THE MOTION AND REQUEST
A NO VOTE. ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL?
AND I HOPE THAT MAJORITY LEADER
IS ASKING FOR A VOTE. SENATOR
NIHILO IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE,
NO OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 31. NOS
NINE JOINT RULES HAVE BEEN
SENATE RULES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED.
WE'RE MOVING BACK TO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. WE HAVE ONE MORE
ITEM UNDER ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. THIS IS FOR ITEM 234.
SENATOR CORTESE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 828 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY. AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER. YES MR.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 828 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CONNOLLY TO
EXTEND WATER PROTECTIONS TO
SMALL, DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND ENDANGERED WETLANDS. THERE'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT WORK DONE BY
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES, LOCAL WATER USERS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT SIGMA. HOWEVER,
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS
IN SOME CASES DID NOT DO A
THOROUGH JOB IDENTIFYING MANAGED
WETLANDS AND SMALL COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS IN THEIR BASINS
AND HOW GSP MANAGEMENT WILL
ADVERSELY AFFECT THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY, ONLY 5% OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC WETLANDS
REMAIN TO THIS DAY, 95% ARE
GONE. THESE IMPORTANT PUBLIC
TRUST RESOURCES CONTINUE TO FACE
NUMEROUS THREATS, INCLUDING
WATER AVAILABILITY. NEARLY 85%
OF CALIFORNIANS DEPEND, IN WHOLE
OR IN PART ON GROUNDWATER FOR
THEIR PUBLIC WATER SUPPLY. THAT
PERCENTAGE INCREASES EVEN MORE
FOR SMALL WATER SYSTEMS, WHICH
HAVE FEWER THAN 3300
CONNECTIONS. THAT'S HOW WE'RE
DEFINING SMALL WATER SYSTEMS AND
SERVICE COMMUNITIES WHOSE ACCESS
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER IS MOST
AT RISK. I DO WANT TO BE CLEAR
THE BILL DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
UNREGULATED PUMPING BY MANAGED
WETLANDS AND SMALL COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS. THIS BILL OFFERS
A MODEST AND REASONABLE STEP
TOWARD PROTECTING SAFE AND CLEAN
WATER ACCESSIBILITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL ONLY
EXEMPTS WETLANDS AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES AND BASINS WHERE
THERE'S NO APPROVED GSP. IN
OTHER WORDS, NO APPROVED PLAN.
THE BILL ALSO STILL ONLY EXEMPTS
THE AVERAGE GROUNDWATER USAGE
ANNUALLY FOR THE FIVE YEARS
BETWEEN 2015 AND 2020, ANY
INCREASE OVER THAT AVERAGE IS
SUBJECT TO REGULATION STILL BY
THE GSA'S GOING FORWARD. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE GSPS THE PLANS
THEMSELVES TO INCLUDE THE PLANS
IMPACT ON WATER SUPPLIES FOR
WETLANDS AND SMALL COMMUNITIES
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
MET. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DO WE
HAVE ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM 234?
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. AYE GILL. NO ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS BECKER.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NØ DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. NO. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. MCGUIRE. VÌ.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NO. MILO NO. OKOBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO NO.
SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. I'M. BURKE AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE GLASER. LIMÓN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE
AYES 29. NO'S TEN. MEASURE.
PASSES WE HAVE MOVED INTO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. THESE ARE
SB BACK ON CONCURRENCE. PLEASE
STICK TO THE TALKING POINTS ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND AMENDMENTS.
ONLY THE FIRST THREE ON DECK ARE
FILED. ITEM 31, 32 AND 33.
SENATOR WIENER HAS FILED ITEM
31. SENATE SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 85 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
IMMIGRATION. SENATOR WIENER, I
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
85, WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE THIS BILL
EXTENDS CASE MANAGEMENT FOR
REFUGEES AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY REMOVE ASYLEES AND
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
FROM THE BILL, AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL EXTENSION IN CASE OF
EXTREME NEED. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BROAD SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE ON THE
ITEM?
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ I DALLI. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO I EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO BY
JONES. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MEN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN MILO.
PATROL. BERG PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SERRATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI EGGMAN.
AYE GROVE. JONES NGUYEN. MILO.
AQUEBOGUE AYE. PADILLA AYE. SATO.
AYES 34. NO ZERO. AYE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
SENATE. PORTANTINO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 98 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO EDUCATION
FINANCE. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB
98 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE WHERE
AMENDMENTS ADDED THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO STUDY
ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. NO DISCUSSION.
I SEE NO MICS UP. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBURG AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DELHI AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MAGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. AYES 40. NØ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR SKINNER, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 33. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ VERY QUICK. SENATE
BILL 242 BY SENATOR SKINNER. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS TAKING UP SB
242 FOR CONCURRENCE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
ITEM 33 ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NEXT THREE UPPER
FILE ITEM 42, 59 AND 64. SENATOR
CABALLERO, SENATOR CABALLERO,
YOUR ITEM IS UP. YOUR SB 768
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 768 BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
AN ACT RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 768, WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. IT REQUIRES THE
STATE TO STUDY THE IMPACT OF
SEQUOYAH'S NEW TRANSPORTATION
METRIC VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
MOVE THE STUDY TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND NARROW IT TO
FOCUS ON HOUSING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
I SEE NO MICS UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. VALLAPUDUA. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. DODD DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO
OCHOA. PADILLA HI, NEAL. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE
WILK. NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DAWLEY. NO OKOBO.
SEYARTO. AYES 34 NO'S FOR
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN SEN PORTANTINO. YOU
ARE UP FIVE. ITEM 59. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. THE SENATE BILL 971
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO. AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB 971 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WHERE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
APPORTIONMENT PIECE AND NAME TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
LIMITED THE BILL TO 7475 FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS PER
DISTRICT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I'M SEEING MIKE'S
UP FOR DISCUSSION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALREADY GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALI AYE. DODD AYE.
TERRAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE. NGUYEN NILO. NO AYES 35.
NOS THREE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE. ITEM 64
IS BY OUR MAJORITY LEADER. SHE
HAS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 981 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
TO SB 9191. CLARIFY WHICH
AUDITING STANDARDS LA UCSD'S
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL MUST
FOLLOW WHEN CONDUCTING AUDITS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THE CONCURRENCE AND ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR. I
SEE NO MIKES UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. RODA-GIL. NO
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ. DODD TERRAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO
JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. NGUYEN. AYES 31.
NOES EIGHT. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND CONCURRED IN
THE NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE. ITEM
65, 66 AND 77. SENATOR SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FOR ITEM
65. SENATE BILL 1001 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 1001 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
WERE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
REQUESTED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, THERE
ARE NO MICS UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. GILL NO. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLEY NO. DODD
AYE. TERRAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES
NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. AYE. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER. ROTH
AYES 30. NOS NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS THE NEXT
THREE BILLS FOR ITEM 66.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1016 BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
AND ACCORDING TO DATA COLLECTION.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SB 1016 DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL UNTIL
2028. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EDWIN. AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE OTERO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN MELO. AYE.
OJOBO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL FAVORS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK YES. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DAWLEY GROVE. JONES NGUYEN.
OKOBO SATO. AYES 34. NO. ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ITEM 77. SENATE BILL 1131
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. AN ACT TO
MEDI-CAL. SENATOR. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO SENATE
BILL 1131 RELATED TO REMOVING
LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING PROVISIONAL
ENROLLMENT, LIMITING SITE
CERTIFICATION, AS WELL AS
REFORMING TRAINING FREQUENCY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB 1131. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. GILL.
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY NO. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. AYE.
NEWMAN NGUYEN. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. EBCLC NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. NÓ
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. AYES
31. NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. YOUR FINAL
BILL ON THIS LIST. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1182 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL FACILITIES.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL 1182
ADDRESS CHAPTERS ABOUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB 1182. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
I SEE NO MIKES UP FOR
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKESBERG AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD
TERRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO AYE.
PERDUE AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DODD. AYE OTERO. AYE NGUYEN. AYE
NILO. AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. I
CAN SEE THE FINISH LINE. MEMBERS
HANG IN THERE. THE NEXT THREE UP
ARE FOR ITEM 85, 24 AND 28.
SENATOR LAIRD IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1188 BY SENATOR LAIRD. AN
ACT RELATING TO DRINKING WATER.
MADAM PRESIDENT. YOU WANT ME TO
GO AHEAD? THANK YOU. SENATE BILL
1188 IS ON SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ADD
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
STATE WATER BOARD WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS. AS WE MOVED
ALL REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. I REQUEST THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE,
AYE. I'LL GO. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. NØ. DODD.
AYE. DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO.
OJOBO. NO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. NØ SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GÒM NO.
RUBIO. AYE SCHWAB. AYE AYES 30.
NOES NINE. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. AYES
31. NOES NINE. TECHNOLOGY IS
SLOW. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR STERN, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 24. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1251 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO MOSQUITO ABATEMENT. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
ABOUT MOSQUITOES TRAPPED IN THE
VAULTS OUTSIDE OF OUR HOUSES,
ASKING UTILITIES TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THEM AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET MORE VECTORS IN OUR
WATER SUPPLY AND OTHER AREAS OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, YOU HAVE ITEM 28.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 691 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
ATTENDANCE. SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. THERE WERE 4765 PAGES
OF AMENDMENT NO. THERE WEREN'T.
SB 691 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
TRUANCY NOTIFICATION AND A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DEL
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
NØ. NHIÀU NO. JOBO. NO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. ACIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMOKE. DAVIS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. NO. AYES 31. NOES
NINE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATORS, WE HAVE
SIX SBS LEFT. JUST SIX. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, YOU HAVE FOR ITEM
30. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 53 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AN ACT TO FIREARMS.
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. SB 53 IS
BACK WITH ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
THAT ESTABLISH AN EFFECTIVE DATE
AND ADD TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THERE IS NO
DISCUSSION. OAN Ã. I'LL GO NÓ
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ DODD. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEUMANN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. JOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. NO. NO.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER. DODD. NO
AYES 29. NOES 11. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN THE
LAST FIVE FILE ITEMS ARE 47, 58,
61, 80 AND 93. SENATOR DODD,
YOUR ANTICIPATED ITEM 47.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 904 BY SENATOR DODD. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR DODD. MADAM PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS SB 904 IS BACK FOR A
CONCURRENCE VOTE. THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THAT ANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COSTS INCURRED
BY THE BILL WILL BE REIMBURSED
BY THE SMART SPECIAL DISTRICT
AND NOT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALL RODA-GIL.
NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKESBERG.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DELI. NÓ. DODD.
AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. COBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. BECKER AYE. AYE
AYES 31. NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN SEN.
WIENER IS PREPARED FOR ITEM 58.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 969 BY SENATOR WIENER. AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. SB 969 WILL
AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA CITIES TO
ESTABLISH ENTERTAINMENT ZONES.
CHAIN AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION? THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES 40.
NO. ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU HAVE ITEM 61. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 977 BY
SENATOR LAIRD. AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU. THIS IS ON THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING AS TO THE DUTIES OF
THE COMMISSION. Ã
COMMISSIONERS, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR CONCURRENCE IN THE
AMENDMENTS. I SEE NO MIKES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN Ã ALVARADO TO GIL. NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALY. NO. DODD AYE. D'ORAZIO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. JOBO.
NO. PADILLA FIVE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB VÌ. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
AYES 31. NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR BECKER IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
80. SENATE BILL 1161 BY SENATOR
BECKER. AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES. SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THIS BILL
MAKES SUBTLE BUT MUCH NEEDED
CHANGES TO THE WILK TO
ULTIMATELY STREAMLINE ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ELIGIBLE YOUTH
FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION? ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NØ ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR CORTEZ,
ARE YOU READY TO END TO CLOSE IT
OUT FOR US? AGAIN, THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT. I TRY TO BE
NICER THAN I WAS LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SECRETARY
100 Ó. PLEASE READ. ALL RIGHT.
I WAS IN SUCH A HURRY. SENATE
BILL 1300 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU AGAIN. SB 1300 IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE AND RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AMENDMENTS
WERE MADE TO REQUIRE A HEALTH
FACILITY TO SHARE ITS
JUSTIFICATION FOR ITS DECISION
TO ELIMINATE PSYCHIATRIC AND
PERINATAL SERVICES ON ITS 120
DAY PUBLIC NOTICE OF THE
PROPOSED CLOSURE. THOSE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS ALSO
REQUIRE A HEALTH FACILITY TO
HOLD A PUBLIC HEARING ON SERVICE
REDUCTIONS AND INVITE THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS TO TESTIFY ON THE
IMPACT TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
THAT'S IT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. WOULD ANYONE LIKE
TO SPEAK AND HOLD US HERE LONGER?
OKAY. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN Ã. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NO. DODD. AYE DURAZO. NO.
DODD. NO. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO ALVARADO.
IDA. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN. GLAZER OCHOA.
EBCLC. AYES 28. NOES NINE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE WENT THROUGH
138 BILLS. 119 ASSEMBLY BILLS,
19 SENATE BILLS. PAT YOURSELVES
ON THE BACK. YOU DID AMAZING. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS, MR.
PRO TEM, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND TO OUR
MEMBERS, THANK YOU TO OUR FLOOR
TEAM. THANK YOU. THIS IS A
WELL-OILED MACHINE AND VERY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF THE WORK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT TOMORROW.
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER
LATE DAY. SO WHAT WE HAD SAID
TODAY IS WE WANTED TO ACCOMPLISH
130 TO, EXCUSE ME, 100, 130
BILLS. WE, AS YOU HEARD, MADAM
PRESIDENT, 138 TOMORROW WE NEED
TO HIT AROUND 180 TO 200. SO 180
TO 200. AND I'M NOT GOING TO
REPEAT WHAT SENATOR DURAZO JUST
SAID. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
HERE A LITTLE LATE TOMORROW
NIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. WE'RE BRINGING IN
SUITES SO THAT YOU CAN ENJOY,
MADAM PRESIDENT, UNTIL NEXT
TIME, THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
WEDNESDAY, AUGUST 28TH AT 10
A.M. BRACE YOURSELF. SENATORS,
SENATORS, THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE WILL RECONVENE
WEDNESDAY, AUGUST 28TH AT 10
A.M. AND BE HERE TILL MIDNIGHT.
THANK YOU.